thank you good morning members good
morning members of the public
uh this is baby district council's plan
committee's first uh
teams um recording and visual
effects um hopefully it will all work
well but please do bear with us because
obviously
we're all in a learning curve on this
but i'm now
going to go through some of the
domestic arrangements that i have to go
through so please bear with me
my first remind you of the domestic
arrangements
please ensure that the microphones and
cameras
are turned off when not in use if you
need to speak
you put your hand up and i will then
call you into the meeting and you turn
on the mic and you turn back on the
camera
okay so that's how you'll get to me i
will say it
and rob the officer concerned will see
that you've got your hands up so between
us we should
not miss you uh that you do not
interrupt other speakers
uh oh if you wish to speak
declare a point of order declare an
interest
request to the german please use the
hands up function on the task with the
cloud just explained
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open other than scope chat
and that you are cont and that if you
are contacted by a third party
during the application you should bring
this to the legal
advisor's attention and mine
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be
asked to leave if members do
lose connection to the meeting
they must contact the member support
officer
mandy smith in this case as soon as
possible you all have her number
i can't give that over
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated film
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential and exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting
you will be deemed by the council
possible
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings
for webcast and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd now like to introduce our officers
stephen
strode if you just wave
lovely uh he's the um strategic project
and delivery manager
in old language he's the chief planning
officer for today
jack wilkinson case officer i don't know
if he's present but anyway you'll see
him later
uh bradley heffer as the case officer
for the second
one and andy pressed the um plan and
lawyer if you'd like to wait
morning chairman yeah and robert carmar
michael which is our right hand
government's officer
and you are you'd like to wave robert so
cool
lovely thank you right i'd like to move
to
the agenda please apologize for absence
and substitutions
i will ask the officer uh robert
carmichael
to um do a roll call
of members present and please answer
um present or here
thank you chair um just uh just a very
quick um
uh just correction possibly from the
opening part is that that was a
with referral to other communication
lines it was
ie other skype chats there are there
shouldn't be any other open just to
clarify that chair i think there was a
typo in your opening part so
i'll just run through so first of all
just to note
is that councillor trevor cresswell is
substituting for
counselor allison owen today and we've
received her apology so
councillor sue ayers president
councillor melanie barrett present
counselor peter beer present
has contacted me and sends apologies for
the moment he has a family
uh health problem that's um
developing at home at this moment he's
hoping to get it
solved quite quickly if he joins the
meeting while we're in the first
application he will not take part in it
but he hopes to definitely be here for
the second part
i've told him i will take a comfort
break at the end of the first
application to be decided
and in that time the officers will try
and like
make contact if he hasn't already joined
us okay
okay uh council lee jameson
president councilman mclaren present
council adrian osborne president
castle lee parker present and councillor
stephen plum
president and finally chair is the ward
member of councillor sue
ayres but sorry cancer super carpendale
who said she will be joining us later um
for the application
in her award thank you
right we'll move to item number two
which is to
um to receive declarations
of interest or not uh do i have any
are there any to declare yes chair um i
ought to report that i've had a couple
of meetings with mr harding
in my role as uh director of baber
growth
it bears no relevance on the kersey
application that we're seeing today
yeah now i would think that so but i'll
ask the legal officer
can you um confirm please a.m
good morning yes chairman i heard that
and that's quite all right um
it's it was uh sensible of councillor
busby to mention that but it's not
a certain not disqualifying interest
just being noted as a um
thank you if there's no others then
we'll move on to item number three
which is to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the third of june
are there any points of accuracy that
needs to be raised
first of all
we've all seen them i'll take that value
then
can i have a proposal please and then a
seconder
members uh proposed by councillor parker
second uh whole second uh
councillor barrett do either of you two
wish to say anything no
right oh all those in favor
because you've been through them please
show oh sorry [ __ ]
for um just testing your rob
um so sorry i've just got to get the
right
thing back on my screen yeah i've got it
on my understand
i missed it anyway thank you chair so if
you could please respond with four
against or abstain
so councillor sue airs four
council melanie barrett four
how's the pita beer four how is it david
busby
four that's the trophy of all
abstain caster john oh sorry councillor
hinton we're aware is not here at the
moment
councillor lee jameson four
councilman mary mclaren four
councillor adrian osborne four
chancellor lee parker four and
councillor stephen plum
thank you chair that's carried thank you
then uh we'll move on
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 17th of june
2020. are there any points of
accuracy that needs to be raised
no so no hands up right
then can i have a proposal and a second
to please
somebody's
no hands going up so i assume that's
okay i would never ask the
officer to take a roll call again thank
you chair
so if you could please respond with
fought against or abstain
counselor sue heirs four
council melanie barrett four
casper peter beer four
david busby four
councillor trevor cresswell epstein
lee jameson paul
mary mclaren
council mclaren sorry it was the mike
four thank you councillor
castle adrian osborne four
casa lee parker abstain
and councillor stephen plum whoa
thank you chair that's carried thank you
very much for that
will now move to item number five to see
if there's any
petitions notifications and petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
um officer carmichael
none received chair thank you
item six site inspections officers are
there any site inspection requests
not that i'm aware of chair thank you
very much
members are there any site inspection
requests
are we doing site inspections well this
is for a request whether we do them or
not
has to follow no
i'll take that as no request thank you
very much
right we then get to item number seven
which is the plan and applications for
determination by the committee
now members i have informed you that
i've altered the
procedure around that we're going to
take item
b as the first one which is land of the
rear of one to sixth
street kersey that's on page 49
of your papers so we'll get that
49. here we are and the
officer um do on this one
is um stephen strode so
over to you stephen perhaps that all
others would know
uh turn off their cameras and
turn off their mics thank you excuse me
yeah
it might be a point of order i'm not
sure right can we just
understand why we're having to
re-examine this
same application that has been approved
by a previous
um development committee
yes what the reason is that we're
actually
this is being brought forward again yes
it was something i did voice at the
briefing on monday um but the uh
officer and um legal may want to
come in on this um stephen
oh you're going to start uh okay well no
no i was going to say chairman i think
he hear mr stroud first then i'll help
out if you need me
thank you very much uh stephen strode
yeah good good morning thank you chair
um i know the um
the question um this is something that
i've tried to set
out um for being in relatively brief
detail in the introduction
of the committee report before you
members that
following the resolution of the planning
committee
of i think november or december 23.
sorry why can't i say i'm sorry oh
that's
sorry that's my fault yeah i was doing
that in preparation
i think as we've got the technology and
we can bc and i think it's important
people see you
okay yeah so following the resolution of
of planning committee um to resolve to
grant permission
subject to a section 106 um
we received um a letter before claim
under the pre-action protocol which
in the officer reports referred to as
the pap letter
so that is a effectively a prelude to
a challenge being made a claim for
judicial review
the allegations were that there were
deficiencies in the officer report and
and the decision-taking process of
of members um having taken legal advice
the view is that really this item ought
to come back to committee
for redetermination planning permission
was never granted
i appreciate that quite a considerable
amount of time as has passed
since that committee and there have been
various
new documents provided by the applicant
which is in turn necessitated new
consultation which is in turn led to
some more comments of a legal nature and
obviously your
your attention is specifically directed
to
uh several of those letters provided by
richard buxton solicitors
that no doubt that you will have
considered um prior to this morning
um so on that basis we're providing a
new officer report for you to consider
you are expected to come to this with an
open mind
re-look at the application consider very
carefully the recommendation that's been
made to you
which is one of refusal um bearing in
mind the heritage harm that has been
identified and obviously i can i can
touch on that a bit more as we
as we go on and no doubt um provide
further advice
um through the debates but that is it in
a in a nutshell
is that helpful to counsel and yeah i
totally
totally agree what stephen says chairman
and i does nothing i can usually add he
said it all yeah
uh counselor barrett um does that help
you out at this time
um i guess what you're saying is that
there were
some flaws to the previous
um decision or
to the planning report can you sort of
help us there to understand that yeah so
that was the allegation yes and having
taken legal advice
um the prudent thing to do members is
bring this back to you
and if you are minded to having
considered everything again
um move to uh potentially grant planning
commission contrary to the very strong
recommendation that's been given to you
we need to be absolutely clear in terms
of your you know your decision taking
process in that respect
um you have a new report um you're
coming to this with an open mind
and it really is important that we we
effectively start again
thank you okay counselor barrett
thank you thank you thank you right
just before we start could i just um
just i don't know if you were just about
to go on to this point but uh yes
all right i'll leave you to it don't you
thank you hopefully it's the same point
you were going to go on to
um before we begin this item can i
please
uh have it confirmed by councillor
jameson
that you will be remaining on the
committee for this item in other words
you're the
reward local member um and you have a
choice to either
speak purely as the ward member but then
not take part in the debate
or remain as a member of the committee
whereas you can take part in debate
uh as normal so councillor jameson
yeah um i will confirm i'd like to stay
on the committee and take part in the
debate
thank you very much that's okay
hopefully that was it rob
uh right they will um
ask the case officer stephen strobe to
present
the application please and will all
members turn them
cameras off and meet their mics
thank you
okay
just to confirm can you can you see this
is this working
oh you can see it so i'm assuming other
members can see it
okay perfect thank you chair um good
morning
everybody um before i do start i think
just as a matter of
housekeeping it's important obviously to
draw members attention to the table
papers
um of which obviously there are a number
of documents
i think just for the sake of tidying
things up um
in in the first bundle um things
may appear slightly out of board or it's
important at least to
understand what order they're supposed
to be presented in so the very first
item you've got which is a appears to be
an email from
patrick taylor to the agent philip
branson
um that document the second which is
uh an extract of the listing
descriptions for the host properties
um with with uh emphasis placed in
certain points that is also from the
applicants
as to is a letter which is addressed
from patrick taylor to the chief
planning officer
philip isbell explaining um his position
on matters uh his qualifications and his
reasoning
um and they asked they are to be read
alongside the
letter which is later on in the bundle
from the applicant
rural community housing um once you've
done that the
uh the drawings uh just to remind you of
the elevations which are in there
along with the site plan they accompany
the letter from richard buxton
solicitors
at the end of that bundle then there is
a response in so far as
landscape matters of concern from
officers just clarifying their reasoning
and position on the application in those
terms
there is then a second uh bundle
which is a a number of documents of
accounting information relating to the
applicants
and an email um from the
from richard buxton solicitors um on
behalf of
a number of objectives drawing attention
to
um ownership matters relating to the
applicant as
pertaining to the site um obviously it's
clear there for you to read
in respect of that email um i understand
that
just prior to the meeting council
mclaren had asked that
we clarify whether a officers were aware
of this and b
what bearing it might have upon this
application
in respect to the former officers were
aware through
previous correspondence received from
objectors
that there were concerns raised in
respective of
properties that the applicant might have
in the immediate vicinity or in the
village which are vacant
this is dealt with at paragraph 106 of
the officer report
the weight to be given to any
consideration is of course a member
a matter for members own judgment but it
is dealt with in the report there
i should imagine though for sake of
prudence it is something that you might
want to raise
with the applicant once they've had
their three minutes
to perhaps question them in terms of
what the status is of any properties
they might have locally
and and why perhaps they might be vacant
so i don't see any particular reason why
members shouldn't ask that question
uh and then lastly um there is an update
um provided i've been contacted by the
strategic housing managers
just to clarify there's precise terms
upon which
um or at least the precise heads of
terms upon which a section 106 agreement
would be agreed
if members are minded to grant
permission contrary to
officer recommendation today so that's
the table papers obviously members will
have had
and will have considered and read i'll
now
move on to the the presentation uh
proper so um this
application relates to land to the rear
of one sixth street jersey
the description of development is that
it is for the erection of seven number
uh two-story dwellings and i'll take you
through the drawings
shortly this is
an aerial map just for you to get your
bearings
members so if you follow the red star
here i don't know if you can see my
cursor or not but
um thank you um there's a red star in
the center here that is effectively
kersey village um obviously across to
the west
and you've got lindsay and the thai
south east uh you've got hadley
uh and obviously then this is the the
main the street and churchill
of course here and kersey mill of course
to the to the east
um just in terms of wider context in
landscape terms given that this has been
raised as a
as an issue that members do need to give
care consideration to
um this relates to the landscape
character types that apply to the
village
and its surrounding area we're sorted in
this location here
rightly um the letter that you would
have received on friday
on behalf of objectives points out that
um obviously in landscape terms the
parish and the village
um in a wider sense do sit within two
landscape character types
being the ancient rolling farmlands and
rolling valley farmlands that's
obviously all set out in detail in the
table papers in respect to the officer
response
and indeed the letter from richard
buxton solicitors um
at a slightly more micro level um or at
least
zoomed in in detail you can see that the
village itself
actually sits um truly within the
rolling valley farmlands
and certainly the the application site
does landscape character type
which is this uh yellow uh yellowed area
and obviously you can follow this finger
as it comes across the village
um following a tributary of the river
brett
um and terminating sort of between
groton and lindsay
uh obviously the the application site as
well falls within a special landscape
area which indeed washes over the
entirety of the
the village and quite a greater area
still
it is this this lighter yellow uh
colored area you can see here
which runs effectively from from from
lavender
all the way around and down following
the route of the river brett uh
down to the bottom here right where you
can see layer
upper layer
so onto the site location plan obviously
we're outlined in
red here so the application site amounts
to about 0.2
hectares and it is to the rear of the
properties of
one to six the streets so i'll be
referring to them as the host properties
which is consistent with what what i've
said in the in the report so just to be
clear that when i say host properties
i'm referring to those
six uh dwellings which make up one to
six the street
and this is the application site here
this is an aerial map uh of of the
village
um in it's certainly in a more
concentrated sense
uh application sites starred in red
you can see obviously that there is a
particularly strong grain running along
the street frontage
there are pockets of development or
examples where that doesn't necessarily
follow that line
uh on each side of the road obviously
there are individual circumstances
involved
in in respect of each of those cases the
matter of
backland development is something which
is considered
repeatedly in the officer reports
and this is slightly zoomed in view of
the application site
obviously starred in red
so it does sit on a a hill um the street
here
and which slopes in a southerly
direction by a relatively gentle
gradient
there is also a slight sloping up to the
post but it's not something that's
readily perceived
on the ground you have got footpath 12
here
running alongside the western boundary
of the site and obviously open
countryside
beyond
uh this is a constraints map there what
this does pick up obviously um
and something that we will no doubt
discuss repeatedly
and in great detail this morning this is
washed over by conservation area
i'll show you the extent of that area in
a moment
and we're obviously dealing with a
significant number of listed buildings
in the vicinity as well
some of them particularly highly graded
the host properties here which you can
see in red
they are great to stylistic buildings um
that means being great to star they are
particularly
important buildings of more than just
special interest
it's quite an uncommon designation only
just about six percent of all listed
buildings are great to start
you can see to the north here grade one
buildings which are ancient houses
and all of those surrounding are
generally grey too
including the berlin public house just
to the south
here just to the north here you'll see
there's a property which isn't listed
known as the old gardens um by
comparison to its surroundings it is a
relatively modern introduction to the
environment
um members will recall seeing it
obviously on their site inspection
what you can also see here is this sort
of brown line um
which i'll show you in a moment on the
site plan that is the settlement
boundary
for kersey um the site obviously
straddles that boundary
for all intent and purpose and for sake
of caution
officers have considered that this is an
application for development in the
countryside
this is the kersey conservation area
then um defined by this sort of dotted
uh um boundary here
which effectively runs um from
uh directory in the church down here all
the way down church hill and up the
street
and then also encompassing um the priory
obviously kersey is a village which is
on a sustainable tier of
the um as a part of the council's court
um strategy and spatial strategy it's a
hinterland village
services facilities are modest but they
do include a church primary
school village hall public house um
and uh obviously hadley is about two
miles away kersey mill is is about a
mile away
so if car journeys are required for
day-to-day living
and those trips would be relatively
short
just to gain the historical environment
it's really important obviously that
members do pick up
the significant number of listed
buildings
in and around the village or this street
here illustrating and highlighting what
a sensitive
location and village this is
also as part of the concert kersey
conservation area appraisal
there are a number of key vista vistas
which are highlighted
a couple of which i'll show you photos
of
later on in this presentation obviously
you can see a number of arrows here
illustrating where those vistas are in
the direction
in which they're pointing um for
reference the application site
is is here the host property is here
where my cursor is
obviously you can see there are two
vistas pointing
at one another um from the bottom of
church hill
and and coming down the street
particularly how important this view is
along the street
um and this uh what's what's highlighted
as being an enclosed area
which obviously members will have will
have appreciated when they uh
when they went on the site inspection
and this is a slightly enlarged uh
version there just so members can be
absolutely clear
this is a particularly important
document reference to note it's
something that's referred to in a number
of the
reports of heritage advisors that have
responded to this
application whether you would say in
support of or indeed against
um the host properties are shown here in
this sort of
this red oblong with an outbuilding
attached this is from the 1841
tithe map the reason this is quite
important is as
as going into great detail in the report
you'll note and in respect to the
various responses that have been
received in respective heritage matters
there has been a long-standing historic
link between the wider sites
or the application sites we now know it
and those properties themselves you can
see that
delineated in this parcel 117
here so regardless of the fact that
there has been some change
in the past and and indeed as members
noted on site
um the uh the immediate curtilage of
those properties
and the use of them is now somewhat
curtailed
the rest of the site certainly does have
a
an historic relationship and importance
to those properties
and just adjacent here obviously we've
got the bell in um
here and some some out buildings um
you've got parcel 118 and 119 here
this is from the 1902 os map
you can see now that that uh the extent
of the outbuilding is gone
um but but uh and there is a an element
here or at least an outbuilding that
remains in this location
members will have seen that on the site
inspection again obviously important to
note this area
in plan form remains open again the bell
in here
appearing to be relatively enclosed in
building form terms
and then with land behind
this is the site layout um you see the
dotted line here which um
as i stated earlier relates to the
settlement boundary so you can see four
of the units here at the back they are
most definitely outside of the
settlement boundary uh the three at the
front are um in fairness straddling that
line but
um as i say forsake prudence it is fair
to consider that um
this is an application proposing
developments in the countryside
um so there are seven properties
proposed as i say
um you have uh elements of landscaping
the gardens
obviously there is a quite a notable
proportion of hard landscaping
um obviously this is a relatively crude
drawing but it does show
where gardens proposed where that hard
edge is proposed and
where cars would come in and circulate
obviously it's important to note that
there are two access points
um one of them would effectively remain
as is
the development itself however would be
served by this northern entrance
which is obviously a a matter of
particular local concern especially for
the parish council
and this is something that was
considered by by members
on site as well for the reasons set out
in the report
obviously officers while acknowledging
that there will be a requirement for
cars to creep out
onto the highway if if exiting um
this bearing in mind the individual
circumstances for the reason set out
is considered to be not unacceptable
there's a plans and elevations relating
to the properties themselves
um they're of a one and a half story
nature and as you saw they're arranged
around a
courtyard i suppose you'd say with one
to four
backing obviously onto footpath 12 and
five to seven
backing onto the additional parking
areas and the gardens of the host
properties
and so you've got semi-detached pairs um
in respect to plots one to four
and six and seven plot five um
which is on this next drawing is a um is
a detached
um unit however they all are actually
identical
um as you'll note in scale form
detail design all of the units have a
gross internal floor area of 82 square
meters
which is in excess of the um nationally
described space standard
facing materials are set to be or shown
to be red brick clay tiles
timber framed fenestration um and there
are a number of obviously
design flourishes and features which um
members have considered and this is
um discussed in the report mainly at
paris 17.
it is noted uh that it is also proposed
that all of the dwellings
would be highly efficient they're
predicted to achieve an emissions rating
35 percent above the requirements of
building regs
with an epc predicted of b
it was indicated that an a could be
secured but this would require the
installation of solar panels or wind
turbine
and for obvious reasons given the
sensitive contact context that's not
something that the applicant is
proposing
move on to some photos and this is uh
obviously the front of the host
properties as viewed from
the streets in terms of
age is referred to in the listing
descriptions
and the historic england response
that they are of uh 15th
16th or 17th century origin
um the application is accompanied by
a detailed uh heritage assessment
not in relation to the impact of the
development i should stress and but
purely in relation to the significance
of the buildings themselves
in terms of their um inherent quality
and again not relating to to their
setting
certainly not in relation to the um the
rear of those properties
and what that document sets out is that
actually um certainly related to
structures one and
plots one and two um they may indeed
originate from the 14th century so
even older and therefore obviously even
more significant bearing in mind this
would make them
or the structures within them among the
oldest in the village
so really important to take that into
account these are really particularly
significant buildings
hence of course their grade 2 star
listing
so just looking across from left to
right um we've got the um
the units here coming across
and another photo they're just just
taking the whole range in
we've got numbers one and two and three
and four and then five and six at the
end here
this is that part of that structure i
referred to which which may well be
from the the 14th century uh and this is
that southern access that would remain
and another view of that from the other
side
this is a view then of of uh
particularly numbers five and six you
can see
and that uh that proposed access point
that would serve the developments
obviously members we we congregated in
this area
and considered that on on the site
inspection
this is a view of the streets coming
down the street looking down
where you can see here the host
properties and
obviously that that clear sort of linear
and enclosed space
running down obviously bordered by
important uh
buildings on each side
this is one of those vistas that i
referred to from the kersey conservation
area appraisal
this is taken from the top of the church
steps looking across
so again you can see the quality of this
view uh that that strong linearity here
but of course picking up what has been
referred to in in
other comments as being detractors being
the old gardeners as one example and
then the keep
at the top of the hill
this is a slightly enlarged view um just
to be slightly clearer
um obviously then you can see uh the
the street here obviously running around
and then
up uh and then examples of other
development behind
uh you've got the keep obviously at the
top of the hill um
you've got those barn conversions
referred to in the report which are
behind
the grade one ancient houses and you've
got obviously the old gardens here
in terms of visual reference obviously
there's quite a significant and
thick bank of trees which run between
uh the boundary uh between um the bell
in
and the site which makes visual
visual connection between those sites
quite difficult um
but nevertheless in terms of placing
where the development might sit
um referring back to the um
the proposed site plan that that back
edge
of plots five six and seven is
effectively going to be running
about here this is a view from the
bottom of the church steps so now coming
down church hill
and then as we begin to come up the
street
you can catch the bell in here and then
the host properties
just there
this is a photograph of the rear of the
host properties
and another one there um
one thing that i think there's a couple
of things to bear in mind here members
um one of which is that uh
regardless of what you might think or
might have read in terms of responses
about the quality of the rear of these
whether they have been affected by uh
modern um extensions or
through the mismatch of treatments of
fenestration or
or detractors potentially in respect of
aerials
this is not something that officers are
suggesting that you take
into account and particularly there is
reference in the officer report
paragraph 268 in respect to the fact
that we don't think it would be
appropriate
to consider the current conditions of
the building in relation to this
particular
decision the second thing to note is
that
some of the heritage advisors responded
in this application have
considered the rear of the buildings to
be uh to quote
unremarkable um officers disagree with
that
and and i think the point made by the
council's heritage team is quite
important that
the duality of the architecture in
respect to these host properties is of
itself quite
important and with the high architecture
frontage
and clearly very important as it relates
to the street scene
and then something very much more modest
um
at the rear which actually reflects upon
the the evolution and use of the
buildings through time so that's very
important
um but in that respect i think it's
important to note that of course
the buildings themselves will remain
unaffected
by this development certainly in a
physical sense
and obviously as members will have noted
from site the degree of visual
interrelationship between the sites and
these properties is a matter of debate
but um the fact that you can't see it
doesn't mean that it's not harmful
and that's why obviously in terms of the
officer report it's really important to
consider
what has been put before you carefully
and why it is that the
inherent historic interest of that site
and the relationship between it in the
past
and those buildings is really um
an indicator of uh well
suffolk preservation society called it
an important element of its
significance our officers clearly agree
with that
and we consider to be a strong
contributor to the significance of those
buildings
so obviously that's something very
important that from members to bear in
mind
uh should that relationship be uh
interrupted or changed
as no doubt there will be transformation
in light of this application
this is another photo now of the rear of
the properties this is taken
sort of just behind the what you might
call the boundary of those properties
now as it runs
and ostensibly this area is is now in in
separate ownership
um you see a boundary treatment here
these are the rear of the buildings see
beyond that landscaping
this is further into the site then again
looking
back as a reference point that that
victorian outbuilding and it's here
the buildings obviously in this location
this is a photograph taken from another
key vista and which you saw
on the plan earlier from from the top of
the bend
uh almost adjacent to the footpath which
is just
the right hand side of the photo this is
then looking across
and down obviously you've got the church
as a particularly important
landmark looking straight across um
obviously you've got
that barn development here and the rest
of the street you can pick up
the application site in terms of where
the dwellings would be cited
is down and in this area here
it's a matter of judgment but i think it
likely probably would visually pick up
some of the development in this location
and were it to be approved
uh this is a slightly enlarged view
oh so that's the same photo i showed
earlier
this is from the top of footpath 12.
obviously looking down members you'll
recall that we went on to footpath 12 at
the rear of the site
on our site inspection
uh this is at the bottom of the site and
the
and the bottom of that hill that you've
just seen a photo of
looking across the car park of the
berlin
and another property here now on the
plans it's showing that this area
would be thickened up there would be
further landscaping just inside this
boundary
this is a view then from that same
location but looking across
to where the host properties are beyond
these
these trees
this is a view then uh from the
uh the kersey road um as it comes along
here and the bend
so footpath 12 then he's up and then
running down
so across the brow this hill the
application site is
is sitting in this location here
uh that then members is effectively the
the presentation on
sorry it's not the the flashy uh type
that you're used to this is slightly no
frills but
hopefully it conveys the information
that you need to bear in mind but
you are obviously directed to the
content of the committee report
where the recommendation is one of
refusal
obviously officers do note the history
here um i can only stress that
you know your decision today members is
a matter of your own judgments
you have a recommendation before you um
it's really important to stress there's
no doubt we will cover
throughout this meeting that you do have
statutory legal duties to adhere to here
today
and that is particularly in relation to
heritage if there is a finding of harm
that is a matter of considerable
importance and weight
and there is and there will be in those
circumstances a presumption that you
will refuse planning permission
it's a rebuttable presumption but you
must have particularly compelling
reasons
uh of public benefits to outweigh that
harm um
i think their chairman uh it's a
probably for me to
appropriate me to stop uh and uh move on
thank you
thank you thank you very much for that
um steven australia that's a fairly
full uh report um a couple of fins
before i go to see if any members got
any points of clarification
um i've got a couple of things that
i just wanted to point out and one of
them was
you refer to paragraph 268 members
that's on page 103 regarding the real
property
the the the rear view of the properties
i think it's important that you're aware
of that
and i've just got a question um for
clarification
um steven straight is
you did refer in your report
backland development now in the past
when
um we've brought up um
arguments that by allowing this it's
backland development
we've been told and very severely told
that backland development isn't really a
matter to be considered
uh certainly in the urban areas whether
there is a
you're looking at it different in the
countryside i don't know but
can you just clarify that point because
obviously it is backland development
but uh we we have a load and refuse lots
of backland developments
and and usually on the advice that we
can't take that as a consideration
uh what's your comments on that please
thank you chair um i i think the
question of backland development is
is of particular importance in this
instance especially noting
one of the severe warnings that's in the
kersey conservation area appraisal that
it's
it's something to be treated with with
great care
um i'm mindful that the previous
planning officer
didn't find any uh harm so to speak in
respect of this being a
a backland development which is
obviously a generally pejorative term
um but they considered it on its merits
and felt that
bearing in mind other examples of
development that um
sort of breached that that building line
or that strong
grain along the street would be would be
acceptable or certainly wouldn't detract
from that very particular quality that
is evident um
if i disagreed with that officer i would
say so but i i think that
their reasoning was acceptable and i
i've i've endorsed that
um members of course you're here to to
reach your own judgement
you're not bound by my recommendation
you're not bound by my reasoning in
respect of landscape or settlement uh
sort of character terms
if you feel that this is particularly
inappropriate
um then indeed that would be another
reason for refusal but um
you know of itself um officers have
looked at this and the consistent
position is that
um they don't think that of itself a
a um quote unquote backland approach
is is one that's particularly
unacceptable thank you
thank you thank you very much for that i
think that's understandable
uh rob i've got a hand shown but it
doesn't tell me who it is
um i don't know it's me
oh god why doesn't it come up and saying
you anyway
canceler busby if you'd like to turn
your camera on
and um uh your mic and put your point of
clarification to the officer
yes steven you've you said it was a
you're treating it as a countryside we
can't see you
well you should be able to right sorry
we might need to ask
mr straub to take down his presentation
i think that might be
oh you're better off keeping the
presentation okay
um you yeah you refer to it as a uh
development in the countryside really
surely it should be hinterland
because it's hinterland at least 50
percent of the
development uh proposal is in
the boundary it's a bit harsh saying
we've got to treat the whole thing as in
the countryside isn't it
um it's it's it is a matter of your
judgment counselor busby i would think
that this still remains
uh a development for a hinterland
village
and so the criteria under policy cs11
does apply and obviously cs2 is actively
engaged
um i think that for all intent and
purpose
the building here is outside of the
settlement boundary
and on that basis i would urge you to
consider this to be a countryside
development
it may not be a countryside development
in terms of
you know landscape or village scape
terms because obviously it is within
what is a relatively physically and
visually contained site
um but for the for the purposes of the
spatial strategy of the council
this is treated as a countryside site
certainly in in my view and the view of
other objectives to the application
thus um there
there is an expectation that uh to be
acceptable in policy cs2 terms
there must be exceptional circumstances
and a proven justifiable need while
you'll note in the report that officers
do find that there is a proven local
need for housing in this village
um certainly not justifiable bearing in
mind the heritage harm
and indeed the fact that there are no um
what we would consider to be exceptional
circumstances
um hopefully that will help for now but
if we need to discuss cs2 a bit further
later on um
i'm happy to do that thank you is there
any other hands up
because i can't see any so i'm assuming
that isn't
for points of clarification right we're
then going to
chair there are ones up i was gonna say
if you
might not have the participants if you
open the participants pane
it should show them in there
participants do anyone at work
that's um next to the what they should
have the number two over it
ah yes yes i can see that right
we'll hit that number
number two no that didn't
hang on let's come out of that go into
number show participants
uh it's not telling me who's got their
hands up so
okay
we've got councillor mclaren and
councillor osborne
councillor mclaren well terry um cancel
mclaren next and then i'll come to
cancel i was born
thank you chair uh stephen can you just
clarify
um the rear of the site i remember at
the inspection
visit the rear of the site has got the
public footpath
i might have missed it but is there
going to be
a hedge erected at the rear of the site
to separate the
public footpath from the site
uh yeah thanks uh councilman clancy the
um
you'll recall that yes we stood in this
area here on the site inspection
um and this appeared to be slightly more
open
um than i i think the applicant had said
it had been in the past
um but nevertheless um if i
forgive me on the scroll back through
the the slides
um it is shown on the proposed
plan site plan that
uh sorry there are obviously a lot of
slides
members try and remember the slide
numbers of its healthcare
yeah you'll see that it's proposed for
that
to be thickened up um you'll note that
you know members in the event that you
do
feel that this is an application that
warrants a grant or permission contrary
to my recommendation
um we would be looking to impose a
landscaping position requiring a
particularly detailed
um specification including maturity
obviously
from the outset of what planting is
proposed
in and around the site and particularly
obviously in those areas
that are shown by my cursor here so it's
a fairly crude plan but i think
you can judge members what the likely
landscape effects would be or indeed
what
what effect that that measure might have
thank you thank you stephen thank you
very much councillor osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman um i've
actually
read the question i needed to do but i
just need to
clarification of it um section 30
uh paragraph 33 page 57
heritage objection what i'd just like to
clarify is
and s72 uh it said the enhancement
of the uh character and appearance of
the uh
application or the nose of the heritage
sites i've always uh
assumed that the impact is based on
on on area of from where the
new application is to the heritage uh
application of heritage arrangements
so has do these consist of
an actual distance and screening on on
on these particular heritage sites
to bring preserve by by it's by the
setting obviously by
by screening and and and the amount of
uh distance between the new application
and the heritage
heritage sites thank you can you just
clarify that for me
yeah um thank you um councillor osborne
i think
this is you're almost touching on
potentially a a question of whether if
you can't
see it and if it's adequately screened
and separated from the site that it's
not really having a
sort of a physical or or
experiential impact whether that means
that it's not harmful
i think members bearing in mind the the
um
the officer view that's been expressed
um in the heritage section
i really urge you not to find in
in in that direction um simply because
this isn't about what you can see
and this is about what you can't see and
it's the fact that there is a
there is a long standing connection
between this site
and those properties and and that
connection
uh contributes strongly to the
significance
of those assets so the fact that that
connection
in office's view will be broken um
because of the change of the site which
is
for centuries remained undeveloped um
necessarily results in harm so
automatically then
your your statutory duties are kicking
in
which means that because there's a
finding of harm that's a matter of
considerable importance so
you need to be absolutely clear that
when you're doing your balance
in terms of the harm against the public
benefits that you realize
how acute that is as an issue and it is
a particularly serious finding
and if there is harm even if it's a low
level of harm your
your duties are engaged and you've got
to be absolutely careful
when you do that balance and clear that
there is a presumption that you should
refuse permission
unless the benefits are particularly
compelling
thank you just come back mr chairman
just yes
i just want to thanks uh stephen for
that
and obviously um the area that has been
marked off on the uh
uh location map obviously uh
it gives that that reason and thank you
for that clarification it's
helped me for quite a few years i've
always wondered why the uh
some of the areas
if they haven't got this thing screening
and um
and obviously um distance between those
properties what the criteria is but
thank you
good that it's helped you cancel i was
born uh rob
i cannot see i've still see a hand up
but i don't know whose it is so you're
going to have to help me there
we've got council jamison and then
councillor barrett
right we'll take councillor james and um
your question of clarification
uh thank you chair uh stephen you
probably said this
during your presentation so sorry if you
did but can you clarify
which of the properties are affordable
and which are up for
um open sale on the open market
uh sorry councillor james well you're
absolutely spot on in the i
didn't say that so thank you a very good
question
um it says build to rent scheme which
means
plots one to four which were the ones at
the back here and in fact i realized i
did actually put a site plan
at the end of my presentation i thought
ahead there you go sorry i forgot
earlier
and plots one to four are the ones that
will be affordable
i.e those are the ones that would be
secured in perpetuity by legal
agreements
um to meet the definition of affordable
housing
uh the ones at the front would be for
market rent
i think the the um the arrangement there
and the proposal
is probably something you would like to
ask of the
um the applicant i would say um i had
understood that the strategic housing
manager
um was was looking to come and join this
meeting to explain but
um as i said she's given written
comments highlighting the terms upon
which the affordable housing would be
secured but
in direct answer to your question
council jameson it's the four at the
back that are affordable
the the front three are
thank you um just a couple of points
um for you stephen um
there is talk in the report about the
benefit of
the affordable units but does should we
also be considering the benefit of the
market houses
equally or or to a lesser extent
um and and there is another point
i wanted to clarify with you um the
you talk about the connection with the
um rear garden
of the host properties um remaining
underdeveloped
is that is that affected at all by
the the fact that the the
the significance of it in in
years years past must have been as
as for producing vegetables and for some
livestock
which is no longer the case is that
does that lessen the significance of the
connection
uh okay thanks i don't aside interrupt
you
stephen i don't know whether julie
abbott taylor can help out on any of
this
i say our hands come up oh good well
perhaps if i just while it's in my head
bring her in
i'll cover council of barrett's point um
in terms of the scheme benefits
um council about i've i've covered that
at
uh sorry um
towards the end of the report um
certainly in relation to the heritage
balance
power 262-268
where i give my view on the benefits um
housing is of itself uh an important
benefit
which is significant of itself but what
i do then stress is obviously that ought
to be tempered really
bearing in mind that um this is
obviously a minor scheme uh and
obviously we do have a five-year land
supply uh and indeed
and rightly as as the richard buxton
solicitor's letter points out
uh we we've passed the um the housing
delivery test and and
indeed uh cl very clearly and positively
so
um supply and uh deliverability at
the delivery test due to two slightly
different things one has an eye looking
forwards and one looking backwards
and actually babe as a district is doing
value very well in both respects
um but uh on the other hand
um and as we noted in the um appeal
decision in respect of long melford
um there is uh demonstrated here to be a
local need
um which of itself and obviously
landscapes district-wide
um this is a matter which members might
think is quite important in these
circumstances
so the scheme benefits are there set out
in the report
which includes for example the housing
of itself which
has inherent social and economic
benefits
through construction and then ongoing
spend occupation
the space standards i think are a
benefit while we don't have a policy
i think the current circumstances um uh
in a wider context highlight perfectly
why it is that we need
homes that are of a suitable scale and
and with gardens in indeed as well
obviously the the buildings are all
efficient that's really important
um from uh from an environmental
perspective at least and indeed economic
in terms of saved
um saved costings in terms of
emissions and bills and
obviously in the context of the council
having declared a climate emergency
uh and then of itself obviously
affordable housing
is is an important benefit and a
significant one
um notwithstanding that the local
context but also bearing in mind that
um we simply are failing to meet demand
in respect to affordable housing and
that's probably something that julie
abbey taylor can touch on
um so steven i'm going to go to julie
uh because these are just points of
clarification i don't want to curtail
anybody
but we have got a long way to go but
perhaps julian
taylor can can help you answer this and
to the satisfaction of councillor
barrack
julie uh thank you chair
um it's just yes in regard to councillor
barrett's question
um the three properties at the um the
front part
of the development um are for market
rent
and um in terms of when
i looked at the whole supply and
different tenure availability
in the village certainly they they would
be of
um that there is a lack of supply of
both affordable and private rent
thank you any other points of
clarification from any members
there's no more hands up robert
no sorry who's that
sorry that's that's myself yeah i just
there was the other question that i just
thought was counsellor barrett
um i think in terms of that that
historic usage
um i'd direct council about
paragraph 206 of the report which sets
out
and repeats the views of historic
england which i think
are uh particularly um uh
relevant to that question that she's
asked page 90.
yeah that that long-standing uh
relationship between
uh the site um and uh
and the host properties regardless of
whether they're now in separate
ownership or
or there is a more curtailed curtis to
those buildings now
it's that undeveloped nature and that
ability to appreciate that historic link
which is
which is of importance and it's loss
which represents harm in this case
thanks thank you now other questions
of cl for members for clarification to
the officer
no right we'll move on now to public
speakers
uh first of all i'm going to ask the
parish representative
john hume to speak you sir have up to
three minutes in which to address the
committee
um perhaps at the end of the three
minutes your your
um be there and i'll see if there's any
questions for you
perhaps you can turn your mic on and
your camera on
and when you're ready the uh clock will
start ticking
thank you
uh thank you chad i don't know if you
can hear or see me but all i can see is
mister
right hold on um uh ken uh stephen can
you remove yours
your participation there we are now
absolutely sorry about that thanks
that's fine uh i can see you and i
assume all members can see
and hear you you you say i have three
minutes if you'd like to start now
thank you thank you please refuse this
application we as
representatives of the community voted
against it five times
supported by the vast majority of local
residents and visitors
your officer the heritage team suffolk
preservation society
and historic england have all
recommended refusal
there is no doubt that there will be
permanent heritage harm
kersey is an historic village the
application goes to the conservation
area edge
over the built-up area boundary is in
the cartilage
of 600 year old grade 2 listed buildings
in the brett valley special landscape
area there will be
serious damage to landscape setting
views from the street and from footpaths
12 and 19
priory hill and the church it's historic
england not any private consultant who
is the final arbiter
on national heritage in this country
they state that the link between the
street and the field is a key feature of
the historic properties
it is wrong logically and in law to
assert only the front of the building
should be considered
historic england recommend refusal
the linton house inspector decided
kerzi's unique
single row of buildings with gardens
open to the country were significant
factors
the proposal has two extra rows
inconsistent with a linear layout
half the plot is hard standing the
application contradicts np-pvf
and among others local plan policies cs
11
15 and cr04 there will be
40 extra daily traffic movements through
those narrow entrances
in the center holiday excluding holiday
let's are 18
private rentals of which four are
currently
unoccupied including for the street
owned by a company associated with the
applicant
baber's land supply and delivery rate
meant housing was only given moderate
weight in the vein lane refusal
the parish council has supported six
recent housing applications
the nearby 1980s houses such as old
gardens are on the footprint of existing
buildings
if you dislike their design more
mistakes
are not the answer this special setting
and the grade two starred listed one to
six
demand respect the heritage arguments
against this pro
proposal are unassailable there is no
doubt
the application would destroy kerzi's
historic
character contrary to key national and
local policy aims
for our culture and future generations
please
refuse permission for this vandalistic
proposal thank you chairman thank you
very much
uh members um is anybody putting their
hand up to ask the question to
the pose representative
uh yes counselor mary i can would you
like to put your question
i'm moving camera that's well done is
that okay
yes that's lovely we've got both mr hume
i tried
um in preparation for this meeting i
tried to
find out as much about your village as i
could
uh i liked the litchfield report because
it gave me an idea about the composition
of
housing your question mary yeah
um having worked out on the 2011
con census
it looks to me as if 103 properties in
your village are owned
so i was really surprised in the
comments by one of your village
residents that housing would
vitalize an otherwise second
home village diversity should be
encouraged
what proportion of the 103
are second homes in kersey
good question right well the the answer
to that question is
um that there are 72 houses
in the immediate center of the village
how many are second homes is probably
less than half a dozen the important
thing
though here is the number of rental
properties that are available
and this is in relation to affordable
housing
where the rents for most of those are
between four
and just under 800 pounds a month
now that seems like i'm at an age now
where that seems like a lot of money but
apparently in relative terms
that's an affordable affordable rent
we are a very mixed community in answer
to your question as well about
the survey and there's often a
suggestion that
the the village is a kind of rest home
for
retirees that's not the case there's a
very mixed
age distribution in the village now we
have got
quite a lot of churn as well with people
coming and leaving with i think there
are half a dozen houses in the
in the parish which are on the market at
the moment um
so we've also got something like out of
350 people in the parish
we've got 23 vibrant
charities and organizations
and networks which is quite remarkable
for a parish of our size
so uh the answer to your question is how
what is the
percentage of um second homes is one i
can't give you an exact answer to but it
is relatively low
in comparison to the the overall um
housing stock that we have in the parish
thank you
yeah mary did you want that i was just
going to say well that's an interesting
comment given the comment by
the um the comment made by somebody that
lives in your village
that that gave a wrong impression
actually
well that's something you must weigh up
in your mind
uh mary i don't think thanks very much
hughes
to be able to answer that he's not in
the mind of some of the people there
um any other questions to uh assess
counselor barrett mary that's
it well done
yes hello uh good morning mr hume um
i think you just mentioned a number of
properties
in the uh the one to number six
the street that were vacant can you just
clarify that
i didn't quite catch it i said that
there was um
look at my spiel i said that
there were excluding holiday lets uh
in that part of the village there were
18 private
rentals four are currently empty
uh and that includes number four
of between one to six the street so
number four the street
which as i said at the time is owned by
a company associated
um with the applicant yeah we know yeah
so so it was it was only num
it was only one of those that one to six
that was empty
at the moment yes that's correct thank
you
thank you uh i can't
see any other hands up
no okay thank you very much mr whom
uh if you like to turn your camera and
mike off we'll move on
uh we have an objector uh
and baker you wish to speak you have
three minutes also in which you address
the committee
perhaps uh at the end of it if you
remain where you are
i'll serve as any questions for you um
if you'd like to turn your mic on and
your camera on
and your three minutes will start after
that
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee i'm going to stop you
and ask them to start i have some
builders i'm going to ask them to stop
so that people can hear you clearly
all right that's fine
[Music]
sorry about that um and
um right i'll ask rob to start your
three minutes now
so stop drilling thank you
mr chairman members of the committee i'm
a retired police officer and have lived
at mill house
opposite the entrance to the proposed
site for 15 years
being no doubt that the vast majority of
villagers
77 of those who wrote to the council
and live in the parish object to this
application
kersey is a special village it's not not
just about listed buildings
but also about their long gardens ending
in open countryside
my garden is one of them the cottages at
one to six are left
apart from number four which is
uninhabitable
and has been empty for some years a
wasted opportunity to house someone with
a link to kersey
and frankly a disgraceful neglect of a
grade two star listed dwelling until
recently
the residents of one to six enjoyed the
use of the whole of their gardens
sadly the occupants are no longer
allowed to tend the full length of the
plot
this has resulted in it becoming untidy
and overgrown
i can only suppose that the landlord
thinks this will make the area look like
a potential building site
persuading you to grant planning
permission
but for the moment at least the
residents of one to six share a benefit
enjoyed by most of kersey an outlook
onto open rolling countryside
if this development is built they will
look onto
out onto parked cars hard standing and
the backs of modern houses
historic england fears that this will
make the listed cottages less attractive
to future tenants and so increase the
possibility of further deterioration
the applicant has offered four of the
seven proposed houses
as affordable this is good thing
but surely there are less sensitive
sites in the parish
than the ancient gardens of a grade two
star listed building
you will be aware that permission for
only one house on a similar plat plot
next door to me has recently been
refused
if you think that an affordable an offer
of affordable housing justifies building
in gardens
where is the justification for the
private houses
which are also a part of this
application
the only good the only person who
benefits there
is the developer this is about profit
not social good
the long gardens in kersey are a
precious resource
a part of history and as old as the
village itself
their wanton destruction severs the
connection between
village and open country and is
irreversible
i urge the committee to accept their
officers recommendation
to refuse this application thank you
thank you very much members
i'll see if there's anyone i'm gonna put
the hand up could i just say
mary you already show a hand up after
you've spoken
can you lower your hand so i don't know
whether you do want to
speak now because you're showing on my
screen with your hand
uh chairman i have no idea why that
that's coming on so
sorry right and that
should say lower and then press the
button and see if it goes down
but uh we'll carry on then are we okay
well done um rob is there any
oh yes councillor barrett has got a
question
yep pennsylvania i think his councillor
buzzfeed share
as well oh yes i can see him but i've
gone to council embarrassment
sorry chairman i think you're on mute
i'm afraid
yeah i haven't got a question actually
oh you haven't got a question
okay uh well if you can lower your hand
hover over and press the button that
should do it uh counselor busby your
hand is up
and you're there and uh we can hear you
hopefully would you like to put your
question
yeah it's just a clarification really
you said that 77
of the people were against this
development yeah i looked at the last 12
months
of individual representation
there were 32 in favor
and only 14 against so how do you come
to your 77
we went through all the letters on the
baba district website and
made a spreadsheet of those for and
against
um which came to 77
as i worked out some of the letters
supporting
or even from as far as new zealand and
the orkney islands
okay thank you any other questions
no cancel about you
you're not i can still see you but the
camera's on okay
uh thank you very much then and um
uh baker we'll move on we now have a
supporter who wishes to speak
andrew rogers you sir also have three
minutes in which to address the
committee
i'll see if there's any question to you
afterwards if you'd like to turn your
camera on and your mic
on uh yes i can see you and uh
presumably we can all hear you now you
have three minutes sir
hello all uh thank you my name is andrew
rogers and i'm speaking in support of
the application
i have lived in the area for 15 years
and married into a family
who have lived in kersey for over 30
years i am a former chair of governors
of kersey school a school both my
children attended
in the interests of transparency i am a
member of the parish council
but i am speaking from a personal
perspective not as a parish council
representative
and there is no way i wish to undermine
the decision
of the parish council there are several
reasons why i
as well as many other local people
support this application
with regards to the location the obvious
place to build new houses
is within the village the proposed
location is currently a messy
disused area and has been for years
with no use to the village at all if the
planned homes are built there
they'll be in the heart of the village
there would be no impact
on the surrounding countryside and
farmland and
no impact on the historical street scene
nothing is destroyed and neither should
it be
the benefits are numerous as the
occupants will bring a vibrancy
and add to the dynamic of the village
the affordability of these homes
will allow lower income or younger
people to enjoy living in kersey
crucially many younger people would love
to live in kersey
but at the moment they cannot afford to
do so
the school has lost numbers over the
recent years
and the vast majority of its pupils are
from outside of the catchment
it is sad to see this slow decline
how fantastic could it be see seven
families walking up the hill to the
school who knows
there may even be a teacher living there
too
the development itself is small
contained
and sympathetically designed to blend
into its surroundings
the plan for just seven environmentally
efficient
small homes built in a victorian cottage
style
is appropriate for kersey and it will
ensure
that kersey has played its part in the
national housing
shortage thank you for listening
thank you very much members have you any
questions
for the last speaker andrew rogers
no i can't see any rub oh yes sorry we
had councillors had a hand up there
for a moment cancellers
turn your camera on and your mic on and
put your questions thank you
thank you um welcome to the committee
um can i just ask what is the present
role at kersey school
do you have any idea are you still
chairman or not i'm not a chairman
anymore when i was there we had 82 83
children the nominal role is 77
the last i heard they were down to about
60.
it was just overfit last year i think
they had just over
58 or something there must be low 60s
now
but to keep the school going uh you need
for well for back when i was there three
years ago we needed at least 68
seven 68 70 children to make sure it
wasn't loss
making basically right and how many of
those are local children to those that
come in from other villages
you know uh when i was there it was
about 80 percent were from outside of
the catchment so there were only 20
within kersey um catchment area
basically but some of them
such as my own children have grown up
now so they've
they've gone on they're on senior school
now
thank you any other questions
i'll take that as no then thank thank
you very much
uh mr rogers with they'll move on
i will now ask the applicant to speak
and that's andrew harden you sir also
have three minutes in which to address
the committee
and i'll see if there's any questions
for you at the end of it perhaps you'd
turn your camera on
and you're my khan thank you
uh thank you chair uh can everybody hear
me yes
well good morning everybody it was five
years ago when i first sought
pre-application advice from your
heritage officer patrick taylor
on whether it would be possible to build
some small cottages
on land to the rear of one to six the
street in kersey
patrick was a very experienced officer
who had written the con conservation
area appraisals
for all of baber and mid suffolk and
more specifically for kurzi
itself and he said that in his view it
was a great idea
small homes for local people to rent in
a very expensive village
he said for us to expect some resistance
from a few locals
and also from english heritage but he
would support the proposals
on that basis of that advice we took the
plunge and started this journey
we have had many reports written and
many studies done
we consulted with historic england and
the scheme has now been designed
three times each time changed on
historic england's advice
until the scheme you have before you
went before this committee
in november 2017 two and a half years
ago
you voted to approve the application
then and we were delighted
but a few local objectors were not happy
they employed a solicitor to try and
find fault with your decision
with the way your officers conducted the
application and with us
and our proposals we have had to spend
another two and a half
years re-examining in minute detail
every aspect of our application your
officers have been forced to do an
enormous amount of work
to simply prove that they had done their
jobs properly
and that your decision was robust well
it was the need for these small homes
is unquestionable over 40 letters of
support
originally and an almost unheard of
amount
a school fading through lack of children
a fossilizing village
a post office closing and like many
others
the post mistress's own children having
to move away
because of the lack of affordable homes
she notes that kersey
has lost 35 cottages which have been
knocked through
to make 16 large houses a loss
of 19 families to the village
kersey is becoming polarized the village
needs homes for young people
to keep it vibrant and the school alive
this is a chance to gain seven new
environmentally efficient beautiful
small cottages
for local people in the heart of the
village at a rent
they can afford surely that must
outweigh
any less than substantial harm that may
in someone's subjective opinion
be caused to the setting of the rear of
the listed cottages
there is no harm to the street scene at
all
we have a duty to future generations
please help us restore the balance of
housing incursi
and support these proposals thank you
thank you very much for that members
um uh sure as you've still got your hand
up i don't know if you're new
um whether it's a new handle the old one
you haven't allowed thank you
uh i've got a hand up here but i don't
know who it is so
rob can you help it's uh council lee
jameson chair
uh right uh councillor jameson your
quest question to the applicant
uh hello mr hardin um thanks for coming
this morning
um there's been a lot of mention about
number four
that your company owns that property and
it's been
empty for years i just wondered if you
had any comments on
the reasons behind that most certainly i
do thank you very much for
bringing it up and giving me the
opportunity to respond to um what is
effectively
i suppose as a slur thrown at me by the
uh objectors
the the property was um uh
number four the street was lived in by
an old lady who
actually died here she was born in that
cottage as well and lived her entire
life
in that cottage a true local the cottage
unfortunately
is in poor condition the uh it needs a
complete
you need to complete going over and it
would be illegal for us to rent it at
the moment because the
electrics are unsafe it was intended
that the property would be renovated
completely two and a half years ago
when we expected to be building these
seven cottages
so it isn't our fault it's it's vacant
it's
in fact the objector's fault is vacant
we would we we will
be doing it as soon as the other
properties are
so if we are able to build them if you
vote in favor then we
will be able to build them and it won't
be seven it will be eight properties
coming onto the
market for rent in in kersey the other
point he makes
is that there's about the rental um um
properties saying there's five empty
rental properties i think it's
uh as um and the the objectives
uh uh used my name personally in
owning the property i think it should be
right that we say
that um the leader of the parish council
in fact owns a one-bedroom property
um and that is available i checked on
google this morning available to rent
at 7 00 up to 754 pounds a week
our properties won't be even that a
month
i just think i alter that's about to
make that point
members it is entirely up to you whether
you wish to take on board that final
point
uh we're here for planning thank you mr
come back um so if if the application is
refused today
will number four be renovated anyway and
put up for rent
or well of course it will of course
we obviously we had builders lined up
to come in to do the whole thing and um
because of that
uh because we were it was we were
delayed or refused
um but we weren't refused it's still an
active um approval it was simply uh
um challenged by the objectors and we
have
gone down this route to to
prove that everything we've said and
done is in fact correct
so just to be clear uh number four
regardless of whether a permission is
approved or refused here this morning
number four will in due course be
renovated
that is correct thank you i hope that
helps council uh
jameson
any other questions there's a hand
appeared
rob we've got councillor mary mclaren
and councilman lee parker chair
right mary uh um mccann would you like
to carry on
yes good morning mr harding um
are we ready can you hear me um
i was interested in the litchfield
report because you actually
um that was part of your application
when we look at the present one and two
bedroom homes
in kersey they are occupied by single
people and older people
under 65 that was according to the
census
did it as this village is
really short of young people and found
our young families perhaps more
correctly
did you not consider building
three-bedroom houses on that site
um we we
took advice from a number of people
on a number of different um people on
what would be suitable for rented
accommodation
these to clear up a point on that the
that
the the three properties inside the um
that our market properties are will be
rented the same way as the
um affordable properties will be rented
uh and
it was it was our judgment from taking
advice from several different parties
that two-bedroom properties were what
were really short
because the all of the small cottages or
many of them as i said in my um my uh
little speech that and i quote
um 35 cottages small cottages have been
lost
because they've been knocked through
been bought by people outside the
village
coming knocked through to make 16 large
houses
meaning that there is 19 small families
lost to the village
we're trying to put that right okay
thank you
mr hughes thank you perhaps you'll lower
your hand mary and that should work
for us um kenzala parker
yeah thank you chair um good morning mr
harding um
just um if you could carry five for us
with regards to
um uh page 54 paragraph
20 sets out um how
the allocation of these properties might
might be set out and you
that says that the section 106 agreement
will be in place to ensure appropriate
nomination
rights allocations that the units would
be available in perpetuity
um so have you got any sense have you
had any sense at this stage
that um that that there is definite
demand from within the village
um for for the you know so the plots one
to four
they will definitely go to locals
can you confirm that absolutely i can
confirm that
um i i can confirm that from for several
in several different ways when five
years ago when we first bought this
application
the we we did a uh we put a notification
on the the uh three village notice
boards
that we were to have a public meeting we
put them up over the weekend and the
meeting was to be on the tuesday so they
were only up there for
two to well they never made it because
both of them got torn down by one or two
uh disgruntled residents but the
nevertheless the village hall was packed
and before we got to that meeting
we had already had seven applications
for homes in kersey from cosy residents
so there is what undoubtedly
and everybody knows this if you need to
further confirmation if you talk to the
housing officer i'm sure she'll be able
to confirm
that there are as regards protecting
that status
um i've been in negotiations with the
housing department
and i have agreed that the
properties will first what they will be
offered
to rent and then first of all
that the only people from kersey parish
itself
will get the first dibs on them the
first prioritized priority
and then if there's nobody available
within kersey that requires them
then we move to the other surrounding
villages and then
and and then slightly further out to
further surrounding villages
so it will all it is it is the absolute
crux of our our deliverability
uh our delivering affordable housing
that's it's what we are about
we want to deliver housing local for
local people
and low-cost housing that that's that's
what we're about
thank you i think your points been made
thank you uh no
no nothing else counsellor parker no
no other hands up so i'll take that as
no one else has got any more questions
for you thank you very much
mr hardin right we will now go into
debate
um and members um try not to repeat some
of the things you've already said and
heard and what have you
uh i will open up to today i'm going to
invite the ward member
uh councillor jameson to start the
debate
um and then members if you'd like to
indicate by putting your hands up and
hopefully rob will keep me updated
thank you um okay chair thanks
not a lot to say at this stage obviously
this application
is um all about the heritage and the
listed properties and it's just whether
we
feel the public benefits outweigh the
irreversible
damage to the setting of the grade 2
stylistic building
um so for now i'd just like to hear the
the
um thoughts of my the other counselors
on the committee and um
i'll come back later right thank you
uh right members is there any hands up
uh
cancel airs would you like to start and
then hopefully other hands might appear
no no one's got anything to say yes i am
hi
hi yes um camera lovely
very confused because you know there
seems to be so many um
differing things being told and um
it's um i for one would like to see more
local people living in the village
um but i'd like sort of more answers as
to how many really are holiday homes and
i think we need a little more clarity
please
um i don't know whether um julie abbott
taylor can help us hear
um stephen or whether you might have the
answers
but i think kenzler jameson was right it
is this question
of the heritage versus this local uh
need if there is such a one um
can you help stephen um
yeah it may be uh easier in a moment
that that
um julie comes in um to cover this
and also actually as a response in terms
of why it might be that two bed
properties are preferable
to three bed in in the circumstances
um i think in all honesty it's going to
be very difficult to work out what is a
what is a holiday home and and what
isn't but i think that's
that's maybe slightly missing the point
i think the fact is
and and with the litchfield report that
officers endorse the conclusions of this
this is a village which hasn't seen um
well it's seen very uh relatively little
growth
over a significant period of time it has
an aging profile
uh and and given the way that these
things work the churn
is relatively low regardless of whether
something's coming on the market or not
um it's the case that people who buy
um if they're of an old elder age and
we've got an aging profile
that they're less likely to move and and
that that opportunity
for churn over time becomes less and
less
um you know strong um
there is an opportunity here and
certainly based on on the
the the methodology set out in the
litchfield report
to get housing into a village um which
which needs it there is a there's
considered to be a proven local need
here
um it's important to note that
methodology while obviously been treated
on its own merits in in the
in the particular circumstances of this
case
is one which was accepted by uh the
planning inspector and the secretary of
state
in the long melford appeal um
but that does not of itself make the
scheme justifiable and that's where as
council jameson rightly says this is
about balancing
um the the harm between uh
as opposed to the heritage assets with
the um
with the uh the public benefits i think
at this point yes
probably right that julie um chips in
yeah i don't know whether julie wanted
to chip in right now because i have got
two other hands up
which is councillor busby and councillor
barrett um
i didn't know whether i could bring you
in after that because i think they may
touch on this particular point so i'll
bring you after
these two speakers julie so canceller
busby you're there and up and running
thank you uh yes steve we have received
a document from the applicant
which showed the extract for the
listings for the various cottages
and it showed that they were graded for
their importance
in the street scene was this a
an accurate extraction from the listing
was there more in there that we
haven't seen or is that um
the accurate portrayal of why they were
listed
um yeah i'm i'm
struggling to pull it back up but it's
um i i think
save for the the points of emphasis that
somebody has used in terms of
highlighting and underlining
they they they were a correct reflection
in fact the listing descriptions are
copied
um word for word at power 218 of the
officer report
and it does state that they were graded
for their importance
in the street scene that doesn't mean
that of themselves are not important
i suppose you might infer that it may be
the reason why they have an enhanced
status
93 members yep thank you
um as i say that doesn't get away from
the fact that they are still
important buildings they are designated
heritage assets
there's you know there are the various
values which contribute to the
significance of those assets which are
set out in the report
um but also of course the setting has a
contribution as well
and that's where we are finding the harm
in this case so
whereas that uh that important
uh street scene contribution will remain
where it's the case
that physically the building will remain
unharmed it is that setting
which is making a strong contribution to
the significance
and which is where the harm lies
thank you i think you've made that point
um
yeah can i just carry on on that point i
mean i think
it shows that the the most important
part
is the street scene and i think most
people would say that
this development will not have any
impact on the street scene
i mean even the photographs
you have to get to some very strange
positions to be able to possibly even
see the roof
of these developments so i don't think
there's any impact
on the street scene in which case the
harm
for heritage is purely on the back
part of the uh of the plots
um if you could go to slide eight
please stephen which shows
this the street scene and the
the houses surrounding it
sorry that'll probably do actually um
the reason for my point is that we've
got some grade one
listed building almost next door
that one there yep which
has got the barns built behind it
surely that was an important
aspect in terms of heritage as well
then we've got that monstrosity of a
building right next door to the
uh application site and you've also got
buildings to the south of the
application site
in the back gardens so it's almost as
though the precedence has been
set but development in those back
spaces between the road and the footpath
has been permitted
so i see i question whether
this plot is any more important
than the grade one listed building above
stephen
yes yeah um there's it's not only is it
a question of harm but it's a question
of
how much harm and i think that there is
a consensus
um amongst all of the heritage opinions
that you've got before you
and and summarized in in my office
reports
that there is less than substantial harm
that immediately triggers your statutory
duties
it brings into play um the requirement
to undertake the balancing exercise
at mppf 196 um
but what it doesn't necessarily tell you
is how harmful it is and there's
between the opinions there aren't many
which pin their colors to the mast in
that respect
um officers have given you uh a reasoned
way
of approaching that exercise um between
nothing which is obviously preservation
and no harm up to that that
cusp of where substantial harm
might lie which of course is something
that would mean that in settings terms
um you would be losing um you know
very much of the significance of the
asset which
as a matter of judgment doesn't feel
right because there are a number of
reasons why these assets are
particularly important
and and where they derive their
significance from but it is nevertheless
we are looking at harm to a strong
contributor
to that significance and that's why you
know even if it's at
a medium level you know between north
and 90 that midpoint is still
particularly serious
and that's why members and even
irrespective of whether you think it's a
low level of harm or not and i certainly
you know do not think this is trifling
even if it were at a low level
that still engages those same duties you
still have to give it considerable
importance
and and members you need to be
absolutely clear in taking a decision
today that you are
showing all observers that you are
giving that importance and you are
weighing it up
and you are then putting it against the
public benefits where there is a
presumption that you should refuse
you don't have to refuse you don't have
to follow my recommendation
but you need to be absolutely thankful
and i think
you who made that point quite clear now
um
sorry can i carry on then yep carry on i
mean stephen
that's exactly right it's it's always a
balancing
situation here isn't it you've got to
balance up
the benefits against the harm and we ex
but i personally accept that there is
some harm
from this development um behind the
cottages
it's subjective though it's very
difficult to put a to quantify it in
terms of
of an amount on the other side of the
equation you've got the
the benefits and we do know they are
that's a fact that the benefits will be
well significant i guess possibly
significant
in maintaining the viability of cursing
in your report you said that uh there's
been
lower than average growth in kersey than
its surroundings so we know there's been
very little built
and there's been there's what one house
has been uh identified as being built up
to 2024
despite the fact that there's a
perceived
need of at least 11 dwellings
if if there was
alternative sites to meet the demand
and the need for housing in kersey
then the public benefits of this site
would probably be less
but there aren't any other sites
available
therefore this in my view makes the
public benefits even greater
because it's the only site that's come
forward
to help the viability of the village
and therefore on the the scale of
whether it's
the benefits outweigh the harm
at this point i suspect in my view they
they do
but i'm happy to hear counter arguments
thank you i've got councillor barrett
followed by councillor
jameson i believe councillor barrett
thank you can you take down the uh your
screen
um stephen
thank you yeah carry on councillor paris
um thank you um i i agree with uh
councillor uh busby um i was just sort
of thinking along very much along the
same lines
um just we we are not heritage
experts and and and we we try and
reflect the views of the
person in the street which i think is
you know right
that we bring that to the the decision
making
um and we we do sometimes struggle with
the heritage view
of harm um
and i think that you know it's very much
a judgment issue um
but it's that
matter of judgment of harm weighed
against the actual tangible benefits
that this scheme would bring um
allowing people to stay in the village
and as
councillor buzzy has talked about
alternative sites those alternative
sites
if they were available may very well be
in the special landscape area and then
we'll be having to struggle with
well what's the harm of that i'm
weighing up that
harm meaning that no sight is likely to
be without any level of harm and we have
to
kind of put it into some context of
people's lives
people need houses they need that um
that level of security and to be able to
live locally if they've if they've got a
strong connection or perhaps downsizing
into
into a property don't want to move away
from the village
um against the very
um very nuanced sort of level of harm
so um i think i think you know i'm
more than i i really want to safeguard
those
those heritage assets but i don't
believe that this scheme
presents the level of harm that makes it
unacceptable
thank you i've got councillor jameson
and um councillor busby followed by
councillor parker
uh thank you chair i just wanted to say
that if um
as councillor busby going to talk about
um
properties behind other heritage assets
in the village
and other developments
we also need to consider the recent
refusal by both paper and the secretary
of state of the lincoln house
development
it was a single house built behind
a house opposite this development
proposed development that was refused on
grounds of
damage to setting and damage to the
clergy conservation area and that's
very recent i just wanted to make sure
that yeah we do
consider that as well good point thank
you very much
uh canceler busby
sorry chair i took my hand down it was
all right okay well go to cancer parker
thank you chair um right okay so
this is um as involved in application as
we've seen for a very very long time and
we're going to have to be
very very careful about uh how we weigh
all this up and how we balance it up but
for me
what is uh what is screaming out that
this is a straight argument of
need versus um harm uh
purely and simply and i'm listening to
the comments that my colleagues council
colleagues have made
and for example councillor barrett says
that we're not heritage experts
um i would counter therefore that we
have to rely
on the expert opinion that is before us
and there is 28 pages of heritage
evidence before us um
a phenomenal weight of evidence
uh for us to weigh up and and consider
but for me para147 on page 81
is is really telling really significant
so if we're talking about
need versus harm para147
asks a very simple question will the
development result
in diminution or enhancement
so if we if we go along those lines
is kersey is the street scene in kersey
is the the setting of kersey is it
enhanced
by this development uh and i would have
to say that i struggle with that
i don't think that it would be enhanced
para194 on page 88
chair and you alluded to this and at the
very beginning
talks about uh potentially backland uh
development and it mentions um that
kerzi has remained largely unchanged
for more than a century with the
introduction of backland dwellings being
extremely
irregular so
to my mind i think something that that
councillor busby said
um is that there aren't any other sites
available
[Music]
there aren't any other sites available
at this time that's not to say that
other sites wouldn't come
forward at some point in the future
so for me in terms of the balance
between the need
we obviously have an acute need we have
a need uh
for housing now but do we address that
need and this is a re this is the most
challenging
uh application as i said that i've faced
for a long time so do we address that
need
by causing permanent and scarring damage
to the existing landscape of uh of
course
i don't think we do chair in my opinion
that that would be
um that would be my thoughts on the
matter but uh i'm more than happy to
listen to
my my colleagues other opinions thank
you
thank you um i don't think there's any
more hands up
yes yes please who's oh
kenza plum ah right yes you've just
appeared
okay over to you thank you chair um
your camera no we can't see you yet we
can hear you but we can't see you
turn the camera on welcome
thank you um thank you chad i thought i
haven't had much to say and i've been
listening very closely to what all my
colleagues are saying
um and that's just a couple of points
that i'd like to make past development
if we've had
development in backlash in the past
that's not a reason to allow it now
mistakes have been made in the past or
perhaps something
is not quite to our liking now let's not
try and do it again
and the the one important point to me
is agreeing with councillor parker that
if we
if the harm occurs it cannot be
undone and we as a organization
will be leaving that as the heritage for
our next generation
so chair if i could and this is the time
and i propose that we accept the
officer's recommendation
thank you i will accept that as a
proposal i must ask the committee
is there anybody who would like to
second this please
a chair i'll be happy to second that uh
proposal
that's councillor lee parker do you wish
to speak at this moment
uh no no i've said all i need to say at
the moment chair thank you thank you
right so we do have a proposal to accept
the officer's recommendation
so members will carry on i think from
what i'm hearing from members
it really comes down to harm versus need
and this is a very difficult one um is
there anybody else that wishes to
comment
no uh counselor
um jameson
cameron yeah um lovely yeah okay yeah
i'd just
um like to agree with um counselor plum
and councillor parker that you know once
this
development is in place as as good as it
is and it is
environmentally wise it's a very good
development but once it's there
the damage to the setting of the grade
two stylistic buildings
is irreversible and um
at the moment that as heritage have said
that land
is part of the um
historic legacy of of the umbreo2
building so i just wanted to make that
point
thank you uh
right members i can't see any other
we've just got one more chair yeah um
julie abby taylor
oh yes i forgot you julie i think you
ought to come in now
thank you chairman i i just wanted to
check whether you had forgotten
or not i'm just trying to remember what
the question was i think certainly
councillor barra asked or somebody asked
about
whether two bedrooms was the most
appropriate need
um having looked at the sort of
demographic data
and the property breakdown in the
village
it was felt that two bedrooms was most
appropriate
for available full rent in this area and
certainly
looking at um choice-based lettings data
um that one and two beds are always in
the highest demand
so i don't know if there were any other
points that i've missed that were raised
um if if so please if somebody could let
me know
yeah i think kenzler busby might have
thought or something
well i'd just like to ask julie um was
she aware of any other potential sites
that would be suitable for development
in
in kersey um i
well i will also ask stephen to comment
i believe there has been another
application for a site in the veil in
kersey but um
it's not a scheme that i have worked on
personally but i'm i'm not sure whether
stephen
can comment on that and i i can't recall
whether it's a
full or an outline application but it's
for a
similar number of properties i believe
well we'll see if stephen can help you
out
uh stephen officer
uh yeah hello chair um yeah so there was
uh there was an application referred to
in the report
refused at bail lane um actually there
was a resubmission
um which has also recently been refused
uh on similar grounds obviously the
impacts
uh and effects and and benefits are all
different
um but yes that site um while
potentially available
was refused um so clearly unsuitable um
based on landscape harm um being in the
open
uh countryside and the sla and also
being
um clearly within the the appreciable
setting of the conservation area
thank you well members
um i can't see any new hands going up
oh we've got councillor balor at barrett
chair
thank you just just wanted to say
actually one of the benefits is the very
high
um proportion of affordable units in
this
in this scheme uh higher than the
applicant had
been uh obliged to to include so
i don't know if that's um something that
might influence uh members when they
come to
to think about weighing up those
benefits but it it it is quite
a a commitment to affordable
thank you any other
points of view or comments because we
are getting near to
taking a photo on this now i think
i can't see any new hands going up so
i'm going to refer to uh where we are
i have to say i'm finding this very
difficult
between the harm which is heritage and
the need which is
accommodation to balance
but there is a lot of information
regarding heritage
there's also we've heard a lot about the
need of the area
but members we are where we are with
this now
um we have had a proposal put on the
table it has been seconded
uh to uh accept the officer's
recommendation that is
in front of you on your papers this has
been proposed
uh by you have to remind me who rob
it was proposed as a councillor plum
and seconded by um councillor parker
that we follow the officer's
recommendation for refusal
so i'm now going to put that and i'm
going to ask you
officer um robert carmichael to do the
roll call
thank you chair so if you could please
respond with for
against or abstain so
councillor sue ayers um against
counselor melanie barrett against
councillor peter beer for the
recommendation
counselor david busby against
counselor trevor cresswell against
councillor are we still aware that john
hinton didn't join us in the end just to
confirm chair
right yep councilor lee jameson
oh councilor mary mclaren
against
councillor adrian osborne
against
chancellor lee parker four
and councillor stephen plum poor
thank you chair i make that that the
motion was lost
by six votes to four could i just
confirm mr depray
um yes can you hear me i'm here
hopefully yeah yes i counted with you mr
carmichael
i got six four four
votes four and six votes against so
we're in agreement yes
thank you very much well members um
i now have to ask you um
whether you wish to go back into debate
this bar or whether you're going to come
forward with a
a proposal another proposal i've just
noted
that council sorry mr stroud has
put his hand up do we want to go to him
first in this case
okay we will do
um uh hello members um obviously
uh given what's just occurred um
you you've got an incredibly difficult
task ahead of you now
um i can only stress again that
you need to be absolutely clear that in
in weighing this up
you are attaching considerable
importance and weight
to the finding of harm and that you
fully acknowledge that there is a
presumption that you should refuse this
application
um there are benefits if you feel that
they are more compelling than the harm
that is fine
um clearly we are i think um um
um i think members have voted to say
that they find in favor of the
um um the benefits so i think
we ought to emphasize on that because
presumably they're going to come back
with a proposal
which will encounter these benefits uh i
think we've passed that harm side that's
got to be
um for for something else to happen
there
um well well sort of yes chair i think
that but the problem we're in now is
that the members are going to have to
give reasons
very clearly um that there is noting
obviously the
the history here there was a set of
reasons put forward at the end of the
report to
to at the very least promote debate and
get members to think about what what it
is they're doing
um but regardless they are going to have
to articulate very clearly
and why is there approving the scheme
whether they accept those reasons
whether they're putting forward
different reasons
if there are different reasons if for
example they feel that there is no harm
i i really would feel that a a
potentially a deferral
or um pausing for a significant period
of time
will be required for us to get the
reasons absolutely spot
on um i don't mean to unsettle members
but
given the history we are in a in a
litigious
context um and that you know the next
steps here
you need to be absolutely clear and
careful in terms of what you're doing
thanks chad
i understand where you're coming from um
and you're obviously trying to protect
everybody here which is
right and proper um members
i did say that we'd take a comfort break
after this but i think that might be a
good idea to
take a um deferment at this moment just
to have a comfort break
and come back that would give the
officers the legal people time to have a
chat
and it might be more helpful because i
haven't had
a proposal from anybody to say that
we're going to
move um the um
in favor of of this development um
and give you time to think of your
reasons as well
do you think this is a sensible way
forward officers and and illegal
sorry can i just come in on that before
before we do that
yeah could i just ask stephen
whereabouts in the report
um was the previous
um decision i can't lay my hands on it
because i think that would be a good
starting point
um counsellor
um the the the the reasoning given
um is set out in the introduction that's
from the minutes
of the last meeting and frankly their
members i
would consider that to be deficient um
you need to very clearly first and
foremost state whether there
is a compliance with the plan as a whole
or whether this is this
is in conflict with the plan as a whole
and also move through then and clearly
given the heritage context
you need to identify the harm
and indeed noting guidance have much
harm presuming it's within the
substantial bracket we're going to take
an adjournment then
and um and uh we'll get the
um legal officers
comments before we go i'll just start by
do strongly agree with mr stroud i'd be
saying exactly the same myself
but yes i agree the adjournment might
not know well i mean that the short
break
we should have anyway would be a good
idea
yes are you happy with that yeah yeah
but just to sign post to councillor
busby though
yeah that from paragraph 325 onwards
there was a um for once of a better term
there was a there was a template which
sets out the procedure that
he might wish to follow through
so i would strongly consider recommend
that he consider
paragraphs 325-329 and then the
statement of reason set out
okay and whether he endorses those or
puts forward something different
uh it doesn't really matter in that
sense the key is that he understands the
very clear
route map of taking a decision here
thank you
well i'm going to uh suggest
a um adjournment to have a comfort break
and would you all be back for 12 o'clock
so you've got about 10 minutes
is that all okay mr legal
yeah yeah yes chairman okay though
thank you very much and i'll be back for
12 o'clock thank you
right chair we are now back live well
done
thank you uh right members um
now we are in a situation where um we
have just
uh gonna go to the officer's advice on
the last planning application
uh i'll ask the legal advisor
um to um bring us up to date
ian uh yes hello again um
um well we've obviously we've had a
proposal to refuse in accordance with
the officer's recommendation
that um has that that
um resolution failed by um four votes to
six so
we now have to decide that that's so
there is no there's no authority to
refuse but the committee must now decide
what what to do
as in whether to there will be a
proposal to grant permission
conscious recommendation or to take some
alternative action
and i think mr just before we went off
air for a break
mr stroud gave some advice which i
strongly endorsed to
the members who were in the majority um
and so unless i don't know i don't think
mr stroud and i have anything more we
can usefully say
um but we'll if we see what if there is
a further proposal to come forward
right members uh you've heard that
advice
i now need a proposal for something
from you with reasons so who would like
to start
counselling okay i mean i think the
paragraph that we've got on page 119 at
the top of page 119 which was the
uh outcome from the previous meeting
is a good starting point right it might
need perhaps beefing up somewhere
but from my point of view i'd say that
whilst recognizing that there will be
undoubted harm to the rear view of the
cottages and the connectivity of the
cottages to the fields
the benefit to the village of providing
a small number of
affordable and market housing outweighs
this harm
especially as there are no alternative
sites
the future viability of the village must
be considered more important than the
likely harm
caused to the heritage aspects
i think then you lead into
that proposal i don't know whether
stephen thinks that's good enough a lot
okay stephen can you help on that
um yeah unfortunately probably not
councillor busby
um the reason being that the first port
of call is to consider the development
plan
there is a breach of policy cs2 for the
reason set out in the report
uh non-compliance cs2 is likely to mean
non-compliance with the plan as a whole
which means then you look to other
material considerations to see whether
they
uh support that that view
that there should be a refusal um
contrary to the plan or indeed that they
might indicate
some other decision other than in
accordance with the plan might be taken
um from what you were suggesting um
it seems to be that there was a a
tallying
with the statement of reasons at the end
of the report say for the addition
of you stating that there are no other
available sites
so um and the reason i direct you back
to the statement of reasons
is because this is felt to take you on a
particular journey
which is is the type of route that you
need to take in order to make a
legitimate decision and by which i mean
start with the development plan does it
comply with the development plan as a
whole
certainly given the fact that there is
heritage harm involved
your statutory duties are engaged and
you're advised to undertake the
public harm balance um as set out in the
mppf
um it's going it's going to be very
difficult for us to do this on the hoof
is what i'm trying to say um and i would
prefer if you're not going to go with
the statement of reasons but with an
addition that there's no other available
site
um i would suggest that we
we defer frankly because i think it's
going to be incredibly difficult for us
to sit here
and stitch something together
um yeah if i may come in i'm agreeing
again i know i seem to be making habits
of agreeing with mr stroud but um i
often tell him he should have been a
lawyer so
um yeah yeah he's quite right i think we
we all recognize and the way local
government works the way in particular
that the
significant planning decisions work is
that officers give advice and make
recommendations but
elected members make a decision we
always want to respect that
fundamental principle of democracy but
our job
today in particular in light of the
history of this is is to assist you by
trying to make sure that the decision
that you may make
is one that is legally sound and that
will will we have
survived the challenge made against him
i think for the reasons stephen has said
that we that would be a wise course of
action
i never i'm not i'm i'm not usually very
keen on recommending
adjournments and postponements uh beyond
the day but i i do agree here
yeah i mean i have to go with the
statement of reasons i think i mean
let's
can't argue with anything in there and
as stephen said i think
perhaps with the addition that there are
no alternative sites available
and and maybe put something in about the
viability of the village
yeah that did come up quite a bit in the
debate the viability
and the um the the need for these
these homes um so can i
can you make anything on that to add in
um wheelchair i that has been
accounted for in in roman four of the
statement of reasons where it says the
provision of housing in the context of
there being a proven local need
is a compelling benefit is that does
that record with the old thinking
council of buzzfeed
yes very much so so
you you so you you'd like to go along
with that and propose
that is that what you're saying kenzler
busby i am chair yes
and i do can you spell it out to us so
that we're all clear
what you're proposing and then i'll sit
as a seconder
by proposing that we ex adopt the
statement of reasons
as spelled in the report
and therefore propose
that the as it says in 12
the the uh the chief planning officer is
able to grant planning permission
subject to the price do you on for that
part
one one one five oh
yes that's over the page you've got 12.
yeah yeah sorry i've done two pages
yeah would would it be useful chair if i
read out those reasons for the avoidance
of doubts
yes i think it would be very good and
then if the uh
if you want to challenge any of them um
just wave at us and i'll stop
um stephen okay
so um the application proposes
development on land that is historically
undeveloped
irreversibly fragmenting land that forms
the historic cartilage of the grey two
star listed buildings known as one to
sixth street
and his was in the kersey conservation
area the proposed development would
introduce new building that would
separate the historic buildings from
their historic cartilage
and from the wider landscape beyond
though the urbanization of an area that
has historically remained substantially
undeveloped
sorry through the urbanization of an
area that has
historically remained substantially
undeveloped
the link between the buildings and the
wider rural landscape beyond would be
permanently severed
and the ability to understand that
historic relationship would be
compromised
this amounts to harm to both the list of
buildings and the conservation area
as there would be a dominion
sorry diminution of significance as a
result of those impacts
the harm would be less substantial
within the meaning provided by the mppf
the harm is serious and requires clear
and convincing justification
it must attract considerable importance
in any balancing exercise
in accordance with the mppf power 196
the less than substantial harm to those
designated heritage assets has been
weighed against the public benefits of
the development the public benefits
presented by the development are as
follows
housing of itself this relates to a
basic need and poses inherent
social and economic uh benefits and
that's through construction and
occupation
space standards all dwellings would
exceed ndss as a nationally described
space standard
with delegated garden space which is
considered to be a social benefit
ensuring quality of life for occupants
efficiency all dwellings would be highly
efficient which poses economic benefits
and obvious environmental benefit
in the context of the council having
declared a climate emergency
affordability local need
the provision of four number affordable
units and three number rental units
where there was a proven need this is
considered to be a benefit of itself
separate to the general benefits
associated with housing per se
the general housing space standards and
efficiency benefits are of themselves
significant
the provision of housing in the context
of there being a proven local need is a
compelling benefit
where the provision of four number units
for local connection affordable housing
with three-number further two-bedroom
units for market rent
would contribute to meeting those needs
members afford that control
contribution considerable weight
benefits related to council tax and the
new homes bonus have not been afforded
any material weights
any seal benefit attracts only a limited
weight
notwithstanding the findings of harm to
the significance of designated heritage
assets
including to particularly important
buildings of more than special interest
and the strong presumption against the
grant of planning permission in such
circumstances
it still remains possible for other
considerations to be even more weighty
in the circumstances of this application
it is judged that the heritage harms
while notably serious and clearly
appreciable do not outweigh the
particularly strong and compelling
benefits
identified above members fully
acknowledge that the presumption should
be to refuse planning permission
in the face of such harm however the
outcome of the balancing exercise set
out under mppf power 196
is that the public benefits do outweigh
the harms identified
whether taken individually or by by
asset altogether
even in the event that harm had been
identified in relation to the bell in
which realistically could only be at a
low level of less than substantial harm
the outcomes of the power 196 balance
remain the same
the application therefore records with
the heritage policy for the mppf
and policy cno6 cn08 cs11 and cs15 of
the development plan
while compliance with policy cs11 weighs
in favor of a grant of permission
it cannot override the requirement to
satisfy policy cs2
though it has been demonstrated that
there is a proven need for the
development
the circumstances of the application and
proposed development remain
unexceptional contrary to policy
adopting a cautious stance the
application is considered to conflict
with the development plan taken as a
whole
however it is considered that there are
other material considerations which
indicate that planning permission should
be granted
and such considerations outweigh the
harm reflected in the breach of the
development plan identified above
not least the broader compliance with
the development plan in all other
respects
those other considerations also include
the mppf where the proposed development
would comply with its policies taken as
a whole
as noted the public benefits to flow
from the developments
including an identified need for housing
locally are compelling
and outweigh the heritage harms
identified further
where the application conflicts with
policy cs2 it does so only in respect of
an element of that policy which is
considered to be out of date
and where that policy is afforded less
weight on account of the absence of an
allocations document and settlement
boundaries review
in light of the above the benefits of
allowing the development to proceed
outweigh the harms
brackets conflict with the development
plan as a whole the listed buildings the
conservation area
and planning permission should be
granted at variance to the direction of
the development plan
and therefore the planning committee
resolves to delegate to the chief
planning
officer to grant permission subject to
the prior completion of a legal
agreement
pursuant to section 106 of the town and
country planning act 1990
to secure the provision of affordable
housing uh that's the four number of
affordable rent units on the terms
recommended by the strategic housing
manager
and that the grant of planning
permission should be subject to planning
conditions
drafted to the satisfaction of the chief
planning officer but including the
following matters
a standard time limit that the
development um
where applicable shall accord with the
approved plans the requirement for a
detailed hard and soft landscaping plan
including boundary treatments
noise mitigation measures proposed site
and finished floor levels
external facing and roofing materials
that's the agreement of
control of lighting and the agreement of
the implementation of the ecology
measures and adherence to the
recommendations in the
ecology report in its addendum uh arbor
cultural measures
including the protection of the beech
tree at the old gardens
archaeology that's investigation and
assessment recording
those recommended by the local highway
authority including bin and cycle
storage
that the epc to be rated as the energy
performance certificate given at the end
on completion will be at least
d and there will be evidence adjusted at
key build stages to ensure that that
is on track fire hydrants and a
construction management plan
thank you chair sorry for the uh the
length and no
thank you very much because i know it
has to be very difficult for you
to come up with all that and i will ask
um
robert carmichael if he can make that
statement
of what you've just read out uh
available to all members in due course
because i think that'd be quite useful
i did start to write some of it down but
obviously it wasn't possible
um but i see two hens julie abbott
taylor
and robert carmichael i'll take robert
carmichael first followed by judy
thank you chair um just to clarify and
this is
apologies for any confusion here on my
part but obviously mr duprey and mr
stroud talked about deferral
um is councillor buzzfeed's proposal
still for
approval i think it is yes i just wanted
to clarify that before we went any
further chair
right back to your point
their chair also about the statement of
course that i unfortunately i
i can't write quite as fast as miss no
sorry
could you just come in and say that you
wish to continue or not
um that was a proposal intend to proceed
with
now you've heard all that yes i do
carry on okay um um mr robert carmichael
you're happy with that
yes jim just need a second sorry once
we've gone through the machine
i just saw i thought i saw another hand
but it's gone
right um so it's been proposed by
councillor busby
that statement that was read out on his
behalf
uh for the reasons for approving the
application do i have a secondary
uh counselor barrett i see your hand is
up
yes i'd like to second that proposal
please
thank you does anybody else have any
comments to make
um chairman is he in here to pray you
can say that you thought julie abby
taylor's hand was up i don't that was if
it was that was a mistake or not can we
just check with julie that she didn't
want to come in
right yeah oh that's who it was yes
uh yes thanks chair no i think it was
left from previous my apologies
okay thank you some appear and uh most
of them don't but yours did appear
right there's no hands shown so i'm
assuming then that members
are ready to go to the phone
so there's no way you can uh read out
all that
but the proposal has been put by
councillor busby
you've heard it read out and it's been
seconded by
councillor barrett all those in favor of
recommending approval
subject to all what was read open the
conditions please
indicate after the officer calls your
name
for a gangster abstain uh cancer
um like lee parker had his hand up
has he oh sorry kenzala parker
sorry yeah yeah apologies chad i just
i just want to be absolutely clear that
everybody understands
what this proposal is for um
um i just yeah i just want clarification
that that
everybody realizes that they're they're
voting to
go against officer recommendation and to
approve this application
well i think that is clear because they
threw out the
recommendation for uh previous so
but members you are all clear anybody
who's not please indicate
i think chair that we do recognize that
this is a very
marginal decision it's it is a very
tough decision
and i guess it could you could i argue
either way but
as we say it's a decision made on
balance
and people will put their own spin on
on the balance is the pluses and minuses
of each side
we do recognize the importance of it um
we don't make this decision lightly
thank you
ian did you want to have the final say
legal
no no no just appeared on the screen
thank you
that was a mistake by me okay right
members
i'm now going to ask robert carmichael
the officer
to do the roll call robert
thank you chair so i will now
read out the council's names if you
could please
vote by saying for against or abstain
so counselor sue ayers four
councillor melanie barrett four
councillor peter beer four
councillor david busby four
councillor trevor cresswell
councillor lee jameson against
[Music]
councillor mary mclaren four
councillor adrian osborne paul
castle lee parker against
and counselor stephen plum against
thank you chair i make that seven votes
through the vote carried mr depray can
you please confirm
yes i agree agree exactly right um
carried by seven those two three
thank you then that is carried by seven
votes to three
uh that that has got approval we'll
now move on members we've
still got um a little way to go
i think we have no present
counselor john hinton in attendance
and i think um one of the names
has also joined us is that correct
yes i'm here mr chairman thank you
yes thank you chairman thank you right
rob
um i know sorry sorry uh chair if i
might just interlude very quickly as
counselor hinton has just joined could
we just check that councillor hinton
doesn't have any declarations
to make or any um
uh notifications or site visits
yeah uh councillor hinton
uh no no no no no no no thank you
we'll take that sorry check can i
i ought to i ought to have declared
really that um
for this application i live well i don't
know 150 yards away
so i don't know whether that makes any
difference or not but
i wouldn't have thought so but i'll ask
legal to comment
no no it's um if the the member the
council of busby obviously doesn't have
any
pecuniary interest and really it's um
it doesn't sound to me unless unless you
really have some worry or concern that
if
if it's granted it's going to affect
your interest in some way but yours i'm
sure as an experienced member you know
that and you'd have
said so before now and it's you're just
remembering now that you want to say you
live you happen to be near but that's
all there is to it so
but if that's the case i'm sure we can
go forward thank you
i was going to say chair um i've from
reviewing when this
application came to us um last time in
february i believe councillor busby did
declare the same thing
and um did also declare that he didn't
have it didn't influence his interest
influence his decision making this so we
are
in line with what we did before thank
you
we now move on to land east of longfield
road
and little tufts capacity maori and the
case officer is uh forgotten bradley
huffle i think
yep uh overdue bradley
thank you chair um can you hear me okay
yes i can't see you yet yeah yeah i'm
just saying i i need to speak to rob
quickly because unfortunately
i can't share my screen it's greyed out
right i can't help you there that does
sound like a pickle
let's see what we can do about that um
i'm in the attendees list as an attendee
rather than a
presenter let me sort that out i can do
that
where are you
right um try
nothing just come up yeah
apologies chair that was that was my
fault for moving mr heffer into the
wrong
area
desktop now yep excellent okay
thank you uh good afternoon members
ladies and gentlemen
um this application uh relates to a
proposal for ever
reserve matters submission for a
development at land
east of longfield road and little tufts
in gables and mary
members will recall that the application
was initially considered at the planning
committee meeting
on the 25th of february and at that
meeting the application was deferred by
members
in order that three points could be
addressed
firstly to seek improvements to the
design of the flats
secondly to water mix towards a lower
number of bedrooms
and thirdly increase the number of
bungalows
this is a an aerial view of the site
showing of the position in relation to
the existing settlement
and the wider rural agricultural land
mainly to the north
also members will note the a12
connecting
colchister and ipswich to the right hand
side of your screen
the constraints map identify the
constraints
you'll be able to note and hopefully you
can see my pointer
where the built up area boundary lies um
this is adjacent to the built-up area
boundary along that side
of the edge of cable and there's another
section of built up area boundary
in closing the the dwellings along
london road
you also note there's some groups of tpo
trees but they're not impacted
by this proposed development
this is a site location plan i think is
useful because obviously
that shows the red line site in relation
to the context of perhaps you can see
the surrounding development
which is a bit clearer
this for information is the previous
scheme that went to committee
um and you will note that
i think the the elements that you were
concerned about
previously would be um well hopefully
addressed
in the next scheme i'm not expecting you
to play spot the ball and notice the
difference here
because my next slide identifies
particular areas of change so i think
it'd be useful if i just run through
these quickly just to identify
exactly what's happened under
point one um the buffer between plots 8
and 17 has been increased
um and this moves units away from the
western boundary
it was previously three meters it's now
up to eight
um area two that group of three houses
that sit under that number two
um they have been changed to two bed
properties instead of
three um area three on that plan
um i'd indicate a drying area which has
now been proposed for the flatted block
um area four there's a bungalow at the
bottom
of that um that that
area there which is shown which is
replacing a
dwelling so as an introduction of a
bungalow there
area five there was a long terrace of
properties
along here you may recall an unrelieved
terrace that's now been broken up into
smaller units
um and that's had the consequence of
breaking up the
the adjacent parking area as well which
in street steam terms looks a lot better
we think
area six is another two bungalows gone
in here in lieu of the previous houses
so that one that one and that one those
three units in our single story
area seven has been replanned so we have
masonettes along here
and a new drying area uh and two
dwellings of
of changing orientation but that's had
the effect of creating a larger area of
public open space with a route through
as you can see so that's been made
wider area eight um
the line of the road has been slightly
relocated
this way to the west
so that that area of housing is looser
and also the presentation of housing
along that boundary is better into
relation of the open space
and nine this area here which is part of
the suds
treatment for the site um does now
include
um well that's that's clearly fenced off
from the remainder because i think the
safety aspect of that
was a concern although not a minuted
thing that was
raised at the previous meeting
so that's a summary of the changes that
you've been asked to
consider i think it's important to note
that that doesn't just
pick up on the three elements that
members
identified at the previous committee
clearly
you know there's other changes that have
happened as a result
this affordable housing layout on slide
eight
indicates the housing for affordable
rent which is shown
pink and includes the flatted block you
will note
and the shared ownership units which are
shown in green
uh story heights um the key again
the majority of the units are at two
stories
um the yellow ones are single story
units
um there's three examples of 2.5 story
units
which are basically rooms in the roof
which would be lit by dormers
and those properties and there's a
single example of this three-story unit
which is the flatted block
housing site layout plan which again uh
i think will be useful
um the yellow are single bed units
um green two bed units
pink three bed units and the aqua blue
aqua blue as i've called them are four
bed units
so there's a mix of units across the
site
the the architecture as i said in my
previous presentation
follows a very traditional form
vernacular architecture
but i think the inclusion of this um
site sorry this slide gives you an idea
of the the street scenes and how they
will work
particularly in relation to the open
space area to the top and also the open
space
area when you first come into the site
and you get
a feel there for the the scale of the
flatted development against the adjacent
houses
this one is this slide has been produced
subsequent to the
uh original meeting which again
hopefully gives members
more of a feel for the scale um street
scene a which is on
the left hand side um this one here
and street scene b which again gives you
an idea
of the scale of that that three-story
unit
against the two um i'll go through these
reasonably swiftly because i think
you've seen these all
previously yeah as i said it's um
it's all fairly traditional vernacular
design
there's certainly been a lot of
discussion with the applicant
about how these look and trying to make
them as traditional formed as possible
bearing in mind their location on the
edge of the village
the key one i'd like to get to is this i
know there was disappointment generally
when members saw this
this elevation because they couldn't
really you know
understand the scale of it in relation
to a two-story
um view so i think that was fully
appreciated and
what we've asked the developer to do is
create
a cgi in relation to that specific
building
and as you can see it is relieved um by
that i mean that it's not
seen in its entirety as one whole block
um it does return around the corners and
there's a projection at the front so
it's broken up
visually which i think is useful
um last year pumping station just to
allay fears about what that would look
like
above ground it's an enclosure with a
wall all the apparatus is underground
and the substation is a fairly
straightforward
um pyramidal roof block
um again you've seen these before but
i've added them again this is the views
across the open space
from the north which i think is a quite
a pleasant edge to
this new part of the village and this is
a view across the
public open space as you come in from
little tufts
so again and you'll also note in that
corner there
you can see the um the three-story block
by way of context
um i'll finish with some slides uh just
to give you a context of the
surroundings which
i mean there is an example of one and a
half story chalet but
it is mainly two-story development in a
vicinity
um i would estimate this was built in
the 60s or 70s
this is the view coming through from
little tufts and where you see that
caravan
is basically where the agreed access
would go through to the site
and that's a a close-up view of that
this is coming from the footpath from
the south
and basically is a broad sweep around
the site
uh that's the edge of boundary oaks
development which is a newer development
which has been
approved and then there's a suite round
the site
and there you see the edge of the
existing buildings
tufts and great tufts so
it is um it as well as i said in the
report clearly that the principle of
residential development
has been accepted on this site um and
it's
been supported and now we're we're
dealing with the details i think just
finally
um as part of my uh
report or my my presentation i'll just
draw your attention
to the the comments on the
late papers in relation to density
which was clarified as being lower than
what is said in my original report
and various console t responses that
we've received and also
the comments of the parish council which
clearly are still
in objection to the proposal um and i
think that
that's about as much as i need to say at
this point chair
thank you thank you very much for that
i'll see if there's any points of
clarification i've just got
one because reading the papers and
seeing the
emails that are backwards boards uh
there was an
objector um which will come up later so
i don't want to go into that but
can you show us where plot eight is in
relation to that objective
that must be helpful when that comes up
eventually in fact
yes i will do
i was trying to follow through your
plans but i wasn't sure which side
um i'll get a drawing up
that shows
yeah um i don't know if this will work
but i'll try and do this
um oh this field yeah i've expanded a
bit
yeah that's the uh
that's number eight pen close and i
think that
the owner of that is going to speak
shortly um and these are the units
in relation to penn close so
that plot eight where your arrow is that
is yes that is that's fine that's all i
need to know
thank you very much members have you any
points of clarification
to the planning officer
no thank you right we'll move on
um public speakers we now have the
parish
representative whenever i got the right
one here yes
it's um brian rogers to speak you sir
have three minutes in which to address
the committee
and i'll serve as any questions for you
afterwards
thank you thank you over to
yes i can hear you and i can see you
right i should start then
uh mary expanded hugely in the 1970s but
with a planned road layout of
cul-de-sacs of two arterial roads
100 off street parking front and rear
gardens and garages most houses had
space for modest extensions to
accommodate growing families
it was recognized by the eu as a model
garden village
the persimmons development as planned is
completely out of keeping with the rest
of the village
i would point out now that the only
downside to
cable is a single main access to the a12
dual carriageway via an underpass
more of that later rather than choosing
to build fewer than 100 houses permitted
the density of 32.9 dph has been
achieved by
in our view reducing usable public open
space
there are still two for few bungalows
and express need in our neighborhood
plan
and we still have concerns about the
open suds
unlike the rest of capril most houses
will have no front gardens
facing directly onto communal parking
areas
visitors parking except for the larger
houses on private roads
will prove difficult and tangent parking
arrangements will cause problems
for people leaving at different times we
have concerns regarding refuge provision
collection
brings will be stored some distance from
houses requiring movement to the mouths
of parking areas
and private roads inevitably as a
combination of working hours in human
nature
bins would be left out by the roadside
for long periods should families in
non-private roads have adult children
with cars
there'll be more vehicles than
designated parking slots inevitably
using up visitor slots
and in time over spilling onto the side
of roads there appears to be little or
no disabled parking
the three-story apartment block is
completely out of keeping with the rest
of the development and with the village
there are no buildings of this type
incapable we understand that roads will
not be adopted nor will there be
adequate street lighting
again a total variance with the rest of
the village while vehicular access
via a small cul-de-sac has planning
permission this
ignores the reality that residents will
have massive problems at key times
exiting into long field road
then into thorny road and arterial road
only 100 meters from the junction with
the street
the main road through cable thorny road
traffic has to give way to street
traffic
traffic through little tufts can only
proceed if long field road and then
thorny road traffic gives way
the addition of some 100 cars trying to
exit the visit the village
via the underpass approach at busy times
will cause
massive con congestion this is not a
sustainable quality development
it is a case of trying to squeeze a
quart into a pint pot
why here as stated by district council
at a public meeting with james
cartilla's mp in 2019
because of cable's proximity to the a-12
a role declared unfit for purpose by
highways england with traffic backing up
from cop dock interchange to cable peak
times
too many houses in the wrong place
please refuse this application
i'll rather change it thank you
uh members have you any questions to the
parish representative
no okay thank you very much
um right we'll move on
we have an objector robert child to
speak
you sir have three minutes of which to
address the committee
at the end of that i'll serve as any
questions for you
perhaps mr rogers you can turn your
camera off thank you
and your mic
okay can you hear me and hear you but we
cannot see you
camera the camera's on
can you see me no okay um so
the camera switched on on the
uh we've got ian out for some reason so
chair if
mr child can't get it isn't necessary
for him to give his three minutes if
he's if he is happy to
um do it without uh right
i can do it without the video okay
that's fine you carry on
i would like to object to the approval
of the application plot eight is
positioned in such a way that there is
line of sight into my autistic son's
ground floor bedroom and wet room window
which is a disabled adaptation and his
calm and private sanctuary
it has greatly improved the quality of
his life he is a young man aged
22 and has an assigned social worker
he was under the care of great ormond
street for his severe epilepsy which is
now largely controlled
we believe that there will be line of
sight to his window at an angle of view
that will make it possible to see into
the rooms from one building to the other
and this includes ground and first floor
if the boundary treatment is not
properly addressed all visitors
will at some point be facing directly
into his accommodation from less than 20
feet
he spends most of his time in his room
and the nearest viewable windows
are distant at 80 feet we are
considering some extra screening between
ours and opposite
it will be unbearable for us if plot 8
is built in the currently proposed
position
without proper screening he will not
enjoy the freedom that he currently does
this will be a loss of amenity he should
not have to live
behind obscured glass or blinds because
others have failed to protect his
interests
this will liken his environment to that
of a prison
he often has periods of self-directed
behavior which includes
rocking flapping and shaking which is
part of his regime
when he is not engaged he has little
social awareness and has no
inhibitions when he is in his home
environment to allow others to view him
would violate his dignity
i would ask for legal clarification that
the application meets
the obligations of article 8 the human
rights act
specifically you must be acting in
accordance with the law
and there must be no less intrusive way
of achieving your objective
his accommodation was adapted by baber
and suffolk county council at a cost of
twenty thousand pounds
it is widely accepted that autistic
people are extremely sensitive to
changes
of environment if we have to ensure that
people approaching or leaving plot 8
cannot view or incidentally view his
accommodation
it will make it very different we will
have to ensure that his blinds are
closed at all times when he is present
which is guaranteed to cause severe
anxiety
in fact he will not allow others to make
adjustments to the area
such as touching the blinds can lead to
periods of extreme
unhappiness and disquiet i respectfully
ask if the committee will accept any
future legal ramifications
caused by the approval thank you
thank you very much i'll see if there's
any
uh questions i've got one but i think
before i
go to questions i'm just going to ask
our legal advisor
uh regarding article eight i don't know
if you need time to look at this but
ian um he's referred to article
well then i think it's those of us in
the planning system have become used to
over the years i'm sure my office and
planning officer colleagues have
been mindful i mean yes indeed article
eight
uh is the right to your uh home and
i'm i'm relying on my memory i've got
the textbook
article 8 is home private and family
life
i may have got that's exactly right i'm
sure you get the drift right
okay so yeah when you're making planning
decisions that you
you must give appropriate ways to admit
well and well obviously our planning law
system in this country
deals with that by um uh dealing with
talk of the concept of residential
amenities
um i mean excuse me can you hear me
still yes
hold on uh let my um legal advisor to
finish thank you i'm quite happy to if
mr
if uh wanted to ask me something but um
yeah it's though of course i'm giving
legal advice to the committee
specifically
and i think it has it is always said i
mean when i remember when i did
human rights at university when i went
back to do it as a higher
part of a higher degree we we're being
told very firmly that that
um the only absolute rights
under human rights law are the right to
life which is one of the earlier
articles i'd have to
look to remind myself which one it is
and the right against torture
that the other um rights are all
relative in the sense that they must be
given due weight
and um balance in the in a
decision-making process whether that is
planning or another aspect of public and
administrative law
i'd also i mean of course i'm again i'm
sure colleagues are aware
the disability discrimination act has
some relevance here too and that that
will be
something that members are all mindful
of i mean the the legal duty of the
committee is to
hear what has been said and to give um
to give it um appropriate weight as they
as they see fit having heard what you've
heard i mean i i suppose if we were
looking at
um well we're looking at the effect of a
development on what is there already so
yes that i'm
sure you will bear that in mind but
that's i mean i'll go i'll get the
textbook if you want me to go into any
more detail well that's i think i hope
that's helpful for the time being
i'm sure that's helped us but you can
read up on it if you want while we're
carrying on
um my my question to um
the public speaker um i would assume
and we'll find this out a little bit
later that there will be
adequate um landscaping proposed around
the
boundaries but what would be acceptable
from your point of view uh if if you
didn't want
hedge and or would a would a wooden
um be okay or what what what is your
fear on that
certainly sir thank you for that um we
we would
we would accept a
form of substantial uh fence but i do
know from the the boundary of the site
that
that the existing hedge actually does
fall on
our outside of the boundary um and i
have actually spoken
to stuart mcadam um previous to
um this meeting and he has been very
helpful
um and um i just would would like to
make sure that the
um correspondence that we've we've had
is actually implemented and and
enshrined in
what you're doing today and um
that that would that would help if it
was composite it would help so much
because
the it would give us a better buffer
between us and the existing development
although
it still wouldn't obscure any view from
upstairs
no no that happens in
any household if you go upstairs and
look over you can most likely see your
neighbors
bottom of their garden
problem with lewis being um
commented on all that we are aware okay
all i can say to you is that we have to
deal with the plans in front of us
but i can assure you that when the
applicant comes up
i may pose a question to him um anyway
members uh counselor busby
thank you uh just a suggestion really um
plot
seven and eight um
both houses if we if they were replaced
by
a single bungalow surely that would
um help alleviate the problems i noticed
the plot 17 and
16 behind it uh a bungalow so it would
would be in keeping uh is that your
question to
the applicant whether that would make a
difference to them yeah
right
uh speaker that we are dealing with the
plans that are in front of us
uh if he wants to comment on what he
thinks might look better
uh then please do so but um it was
rather an unusual question councillor
busby
but mr supposed to ask the applicant
that as well
good that's fine uh mr child have you
any comment on that
no that's great thank you thank you any
other questions members
to him no
thank you very much uh we'll then move
on
and um there's no one wanting to speak
there
we'll now go to the applicant which is
uh stuart mcadam
you sir have three minutes also in which
to address the committee
uh if you like to turn on your camera
and turn on your mic
um and then you can start ah
good morning morning yeah good afternoon
i should say can you can everyone hear
me before i start
saying hey you yeah thank you uh good
morning chair and members of the
planning committee my name is stuart
mcadam
and i'm the planning manager with
persimmon home suffolk
members are being asked to consider
persimmon homes application which seeks
approval of reserve matters
for a development of 100 houses at land
adjacent to little tufts of capes and
mary
the principle including highway impact
and access
has been established by the outline
planning permission approved by your
committee
in july 2018. following the pharaoh by
the committee
earlier this year further discussions
have taken place with your officers
the local ward member and capless mary
parish council
resulting in the proposals before
members today
the reasons for deferral is highlighted
in the council minutes where
to seek improvement of the design of the
flats alter the mix towards a lower
number of bedrooms
and to increase the number of bungalows
in respect to flats we considered
reducing the height to two and a half or
two story
however this impacted in viability and
also compromised affordable housing and
offer
which has been agreed with your housing
officer
the three-story element whilst
acknowledged is not commonplace in
capless and mary
is considered to be an acceptable form
of building which adds visual interest
and provides a key
focal point in the centre of the
development which will not readily be
viewed from outside the site
street images have been provided and
computer-generated images
commissioned to give members an
impression of what the building will
look like
and the design is very similar to the
flats approved by the committee
and hardly in august last year
members will be pleased to know that
concerns made about the lack of an
external drying area
have been addressed with the provision
of an enclosed external drying area to
the rear
the remaining concerns of the committee
center around the housing mix
in particular seeking to increase the
number of two-bedroom dwellings
and increasing the number of bungalows
within the development
your previous and revised mix is
highlighted in paragraph 12
8 of your report i'm pleased to report
the number of two bed units has
increased from 28 to 34
which includes three additional private
two bed bungalows
during discussions with the parish
council following the committee
requests for additional two bed units
along with smaller
rather than large bungalows was
something they were keen to see in
cables in mary
as this would better reflect local
housing requirements the additional
bunglers have been positioned to the
southern part of the site
to allow for a lower edge of the
development adjacent to the footpath
that runs through the expanded public
open space
this means that the 42 of the units are
now one to three bed in size
and sixty eight percent of two to three
bed dwellings
the houses will be built to modern
sustainability standards
and parking accords with suffolk county
council's adopted parking standards 228
spaces
plus 26 visitor spaces and you'll note
from your papers that no objection has
been received
from highway in this regard the
objections from the parish council and
third parties are noted
however we believe that the revised
proposals provide a balanced mix of
housing
at an appropriate density for this
location whilst also providing 20
28 sorry of the site areas public open
space
that's nearly three times the policy
requirement of ten percent
an area of play is designated in the
open space of the north
and persimmon is happy to accept the
condition to secure appropriate play
equipment as necessary
members will note from the papers there
are no other objections to the proposals
from statutory council tees we've worked
with your officers to ensure that
development will make an attractive
addition to the village
and we welcome the positive officer
recommendation and hope that members can
approve the application
which will deliver much needed high
quality homes
thank you for allowing me to address you
this afternoon
thank you very much for that
mr mcadam yes uh we
are dealing with reserve matters and uh
i do
note that you've um have answered some
of the queries we've got or all of them
um could i just put it to you you heard
an objector
hello you've disappeared not that yeah
yeah
you heard an objector um who lives
near plot eight and we've been shown
where that is
um who has a lack of um uh
hatred uh it's on his side and obviously
he can
uh infill on that but we all know that
will take time to grow
uh he would be quite happy from the
sayings of what he was saying
uh if you put up a wooden fence along
there
surely that would be a small price to
pay but
um rather than us have to go into
putting in
um conditions and what have you what's
your feeling on that
yeah thank you for giving me the chance
to to respond to that
um the issue only came up earlier this
week
um when i was alerted to a potential
problem
and first thing to say is i don't
believe there's a an issue
of overlooking and in planning terms
that should would merit a reason for
refusal but that's for members to decide
but that being said the angle of the
house and the fact is at the end of the
turning point for
the um penn coast which is adjacent
means that there's
there's limited impact on neighboring
properties
but we hear what the objector said in
terms of his autistic son
and having met mr child in sight and
giving them assurance that we're
perfectly happy
to erect a fence 1.8 meter fence
along that boundary and i'm hoping that
that will set his concerns
aside
thank you very much for that um um
knowing your
track record mr mcadam oh i think your
word is good
so i i'm happy and i hopefully the um
objective will be but members have you
any questions
i can say a hand but i don't know whose
it is
we've got counselor airs right
and then yeah uh
i can't just not showing who the other
one is yeah i'll get right into letters
you carry on
thank you very much for the presentation
um i noted when
um the things that we were worried about
on page 31
and we had suggested that we didn't have
private roads
and that they were all um adopted roads
what's happening about that
um well there's a bit of a hybrid
approach to the scheme here
the adopted roads form the main routes
through the site but there will be
private ways which will be conveyed over
to
residents when they purchase the
property is fairly standard procedures
and developments and what it does is it
makes the overall
composition look a lot less engineered
and gives it a little bit
less formal route through these private
drives so they would be maintained by
the residents and conveyed to a number
of them who
are accessed off that private drive
so the adopted areas are the main routes
which will be
taken a little bit of county council and
does that apply with lights
if there was to be adopted and that's
what we're proposing through the scheme
the the adopted streets will be lit but
the private drives won't be lit thank
you
um any other did you find out who the
other hand was
yes it was councillor osborne okay
right cancel i was born uh yeah thank
you mr chairman
just a couple of questions too to uh
uh um to mr mccallum
um first of all i notice you have
turning heads in in on these roads
will that uh well that impact on on
on people parking there because on
on other developments where you have
turning heads that's exactly what's
happened
they've used the turning heads as
parking spaces
um and the other one was um
i noticed the the uh reference to the
um rear of the uh block of the
three-story house the the the entrance
is at the back
does that create a problem for um
has the police have made any um
inferences into uh into anti-social
behavior or
problems that arise from this place
yeah just turn into the uh
the last point there about the access
only from the rear the police haven't
made any comment on
the access point to the rear from our
perspective
and a practicality point of view um
we did consider looking at putting a
front door on
the flats and that was suggested by one
of the members of the last committee
the reason we haven't included a front
door is basically it
involves uh re um configuring the whole
of the internal layout
for the flats because they provide a
communal stairwell which is located at
the front of the flats
but also another point worth mentioning
and i i think this
is mentioned in your report um is that
if there was a front door on the
property it could lead to
deliveries being made people bumping up
on the front cab
at that critical juncture in the center
of the site
highway safety implications so we have
left it as
was originally proposed with the parking
to the rear which means that people can
park at the rear door and walk straight
into
the apartment block so um
at hand there for people to use which is
easier to use than
the than walking around to the front
door in some ways probably safer than
that
yeah thank you and just going back to
the front first point you made about the
the turning points no parking spaces are
actually
um allocated within these turning points
and looking through
the layout that you have before you and
there's not an awful lot of scope to
park
in the tunneling heads themselves
because most of them
either access the private drives or
there's visitor spaces next to them
anyway so i don't
foresee that as a problem um so there's
and the other thing to point out is that
we're actually in excess
of the parking requirements which
requires 25 percent parking through the
scheme
we are actually in excess of that
providing 26
visitor parking spaces so there should
be ample
provision within the development for
visitors to park
thank you thank you stuart um i'd just
like to
peter if i may just yeah thanks thanks
stuart for
the uh additional uh swift boxes for the
for the houses uh that's very much
welcome and thank you stuart for
putting it on the conditions thank you
yeah no problem at all welcome to
pleased to do thank you i've got
councillor busby next
thank you stuart
hello thank you thank you for your smile
and so you're good all right
he doesn't want to be smiling no i said
you asked about i'm always smiling
yeah thank you for the documents you
sent out i think we all found that that
was very useful and i'd
recommend uh robert that you ask for
that from
any developer um i think it's useful the
point that i made which you obviously
heard about
um plots seven and eight which are
alongside
eight pen close we could resolve that
problem by putting a single bungalow in
there which
i think would a help the number of
bungalows obviously
and it i think it's always good to have
single story buildings next door to
the the boundary what are your views on
that
yeah thank you for your comments um you
know we have considered that
um you know previously but the site is
you know there's nightline permission in
place for 100 units
and you know that is what we want to
construct here
we don't want to cause problems with
with neighbours and i believe that
the layout as proposed doesn't cause any
undue harm to
the amenities enjoyed by any of the the
properties that bound
the site and we've heard from mr child
early and we've given an assurance that
we're quite happy to
erect offense up there to maintain his
privacy and and enhance
uh the quality of life for his son um
i don't believe there's a planning
reason for refusal on these grounds
and you know we're a business we want to
get houses built and
and and comply with the standards of the
the
permission that we have for 100 units
the other thing i would say in terms of
density we've got a good density here
and we also provide us endless speech
earlier
28 public open space within the site was
i think we've got
an acceptable uh format here and we
wouldn't really
seek to reduce the the units here for no
sound planning reasons
uh but again that's something for
members to to consider but
you know considering the view of the
member members must look at the proposal
before them
thank you um sorry can i come back on
that actually
you have planning approval for up to
100. we do we are you're absolutely
right
i mean make quite a bit of difference we
would like to build up to 100 and for
the reasons that explained
the site i'd like to build a hundred yes
we'd like to build a hundred
and then i think you made your point on
that one canceler busby carry on
he'll re he'll quote viability as a
problem
um but if we looked at the last set of
results i got for persimmon
they're averaging uh a profit of sixty
one thousand pounds per house
question two is the question viability i
haven't raised that because that that
isn't an issue for me it's
the planning merits of the scheme before
members okay so it's
it's not a viability issue then that
you're putting in all these private
drives
it's totally unreasonable to expect
people to be forking out to
keep the road surfaces good i mean
especially where we've got affordable
housing in here
these people can hardly afford a house
let alone repairing roads
can you help us i don't i don't really
have anything
to add to what i've said already except
that we put a proposal in which has to
be
assessed against the that's planning
merits and if members
do find that unacceptable then they will
make the the views known but we believe
we've got a site
of 100 houses which we've got permission
for up to 100
and it can accommodate the 100 within
the site without
causing immunity issues and meeting all
the policy open space requirements
and the front i guess the final point um
oh no not quite fun but the if you look
at your section you know
those round circle things you've got
item number seven
which yeah i've got a plan in front of
me bottom right hand corner of the
layout you've redesigned that layout
um which provides more public open space
but it does then provide this block of
parking
and it's the parking spaces are quite a
long way from some of the properties
um i have to say i don't think that's
necessarily an improvement
uh yeah just to come back in that it was
a case of compromise here i think in
that particular corner
what we were seeking to do was reduce
the private road i don't know if bradley
can bring up
the previous arrangement but there was a
private road
uh traversing that public open space
area at the bottom in the south
east corner and by removing that and
putting parking to the rear
we've opened up another area which
provides meaningful open space
which we think is a benefit
okay i'm sorry i can't really see that
on my screen here i don't have the other
plan
in front of me but there was an element
of of courtyard parking
on the previous um layout which you can
see before you now to the rear of these
can you move the
pointer bradley that's it to where we're
talking yes that's that area yeah that's
that's a parking cooler which was there
previously
thank you what okay surface will the
private roads
take take that screen off please
yeah what what surface did you say yeah
yeah i think they're generally
a black top or or sets of some
behaviors of some sort but that will be
agreed under the
external work specification which is um
conditioned okay okay thank you thank
you
thank you very much any other questions
i can't say any hands up
only cancel the buzzboos if you'd like
to lower yours we've got council
barrett chair councillor barrett thank
you
um just uh stuart um i know
the camera oh sorry
um i know the the um
flats are part of the affordable housing
provision
um and in the report it talks about
the design of the flats fully compliant
with building ranks yes
does that include lifts they won't have
a lift in them
in terms of um they meet every other
aspect of the building regulations
including fire
which was mentioned previously as well
um but they won't have a lift in them no
because that would really enhance
the provision for affordable for
disabled
people wouldn't it if they'd had lifts
uh
yeah we do it's not something we
normally do as part of our offer but
if there was a requirement for a
disabled
we could accommodate them in the ground
uh
floor level so there's two flats at
ground floor as well so there's an
opportunity there for
the housing association who takes us on
to accommodate them
at the lower levels see it seems a
wasted opportunity when you're building
not to incorporate a lift i mean i'm
thinking of a development i know of in
cornard
where they didn't put lifts in and it
limits the
the people who can go into the upper
floor uh units
elderly they don't have to be disabled
to neither lift or parents
struggling with shopping and um and
children
so it really seems to be a very
short-sighted not
not to put a lift in okay i mean it's
not something we're proposing here but
hear what you're saying and i can take
that away
and speak to the players to be and maybe
it's something we could consider in
future developments
goodbye thank you thank you
any other questions i can see no hands
so i'm going to move on thank you um mr
mccann
thank you uh we'll go to the ward member
now and the ward members
councillor sue carpendale you soon have
five minutes to address the committee
i'll see if there's any questions
afterwards hello to you thank you chair
stop my stopwatch um
yes thank you and good afternoon
everyone uh just a few comments
um i'm aware and i want to acknowledge
that the applicants through
stuart mcadam have consulted and worked
to improve their original design for
this site
the art run approval for which they got
two years ago
um but you you don't really need me to
remind you that despite the improvements
locally this is a hugely unpopular
decision
because of the access to little tufts
until this point it was a small
quiet residential close and this
development frankly will impinge on all
the other small quiet
developmental um uh closes along loca
and longfield road as well and you will
also have noted that
there are some concerns about potential
vulnerability to localized flooding
so i'm not going to repeat all the
concerns expressed elsewhere by the
parish council and mr child but i do
endorse them
um your february meeting uh deferred a
decision on those
on three grounds and and those are the
ones that that i will address
so on the plus side you will have noted
there are now three small bungalows for
market sale
and four affordable bungalows whether
that's sufficient to meet local needs
or you're directed from february is
obviously something that you will debate
there are also some improvements to
footpaths and i'm pleased to see the
open space
here and there but again are they
sufficient
and i'm also pleased to see the two
useful outside drying areas
proposed to next to some of the
affordable properties
so in terms of the housing mix uh it's
good to see
35 affordable properties and 30 of them
including the bungalows are one and two
bedroom homes
on the downside many of these are only
allocated one and a half parking spaces
which maybe assume single adult
occupancy
um or maybe some neighborhood battles in
the morning and evening
there are only a handful of what i would
call genuine visitors parking spaces on
the rest of the site
and while the overall layout encourages
parking behind the dwellings and that's
a feature that i
that i like i do think that the
on-street parking is inevitable
at the market homes 24 of the 65 are
four-bedroom properties so that's still
quite a substantial number 29 3 bedroom
12
including three bungalows are two
bedrooms so that's also good
so it is a better mix of sizes even if
it's still not
ideal i have however some great
reservations about the size of the rooms
in many of these properties
whether they're large enough to to
function as bedrooms or as living
living space and overall the site
remains cramped with a density greater
than the rest of the village
and therefore it's out of keeping
especially for a development on this
scale
i do have concerns that an estate of
this nature
might be distinctly different in
character from the rest of the village
and and not in a positive sense
the three-story height of the apartment
block has not been reduced i understand
the arguments behind that
but again it's out of keeping with the
rest of the village
and i think whether we like capped or
not it's a matter of context
assessment um uh uh individual judgment
and aesthetics and again that's down to
to members to decide um
i note what what stewart has said about
building regulations but i i still have
concerns about multi-story
multi-occupancy uh buildings um
in the event of a fire or other other
accidents
apart from the planning considerations i
do want to pick up
mr child's comments um i
i think his his difficulty stems partly
from the admission on the plans of an
important detail concerning his property
and the site boundary alongside eight
pen close
and that's that's the first one north of
little talks
the plans don't show that his property
has both an extension and an outbuilding
uh pretty much onto the boundary of his
property and both of those are missing
from the drawings
now i'm aware that stuart has very
recently visited
the household and spoken to mr child and
they've come to this verbal agreement
that that's been referred to
earlier today that does include
a 1.8 metre close boarded or something
similar boundary fence
located where the land register records
the boundary not what's on these
drawings
and there needs to be a facility to
enable access
to maintain the property so that is
something i think that
they have talked about um and difficult
to know how we can enshrine that
in our permissions um high offense is
important to this
this household you know that and it
concerns the safeguarding
and human rights of a disabled young
adult
and i use the word safeguarding quite
deliberately
in order to preserve the privacy and
protection of this individual
documents supporting these concerns
haven't been tabled for committee
but should committee be minded to
approve these reserve matters today or
at some future date
i would ask that perhaps when any
conditions are being worded
and framed whilst not a specific
planning point could reference be made
to the verbal agreement between the
householder and mr
mcadams so that um we're in no doubt
about its importance
thank you thank you thank you very much
i'm not sure whether we can word that in
the condition but uh i'll find out
whether a note can be added
or what our legal advisor might be able
to help us there ian can you help out on
that very last point before i go for
questions
it's really this is more a matter for
the case officer to advise but
i don't know whether and i don't think
an informative
is possible bradley might want to
comment on that
yeah because we've heard it from the
applicant and counselor carpenter
has reiterated that i've commented on it
um i i think we would take a very dim
view if they didn't hold to their word
but the case officer can you just
clarify this point could you add a note
to it
yep bradley thank you jer yes
um we have considered that
issue as well with regard to an
agreement i think it's important to
emphasize that my recommendation to
committee in terms of amenity impact
wasn't predicated on such an agreement
being
reached that's important to emphasize
that agreement
is between the parties involved is out
with planning considerations as far as
i'm concerned
having said that i fully acknowledge
that
some agreement has been reached and
i think that in terms of
dealing with it or having that reflected
in a planning permission
you could why a condition could be
framed around
soft landscaping and hard landscaping
and in particular
details in relation to the the boundary
that's in question because i think
that's the simplest way of dealing
with it in order that as part of an
application submission
we would expect a particular detail to
be
uh submitted which deals with that
particular issue
so i don't know if ian's got anything to
say on that but that would be my
my way of approaching that particular
thing so
if we were minded to go down the road of
approval
could you while you're sitting there
write a sentence out that would
incorporate that extra condition
which we yes if we went down that road
we could add to it i think that would
certainly i i don't i personally uh
known
mr sturt mcadam i would think he'd keep
his word but i do take your point i do
understand what sue is saying
i i also um respect what's do it um
as miss stewart's word but um he's not
he's not the man with the digger on the
side
thank you
mr mcadam sure raised his hand if you
did
want to quickly return to him and ask
him the league and advisor he's shaking
his head that i should
no no it is it is appropriate we can be
sufficiently flexible you can
you can hear from him again yes do so
thank you very much
uh mr mccann would you like you've heard
the concerns from
uh the local ward members councillor of
cartondale uh you've heard the planning
officer you've heard the legal side of
it and you've heard my comments on it
would you now like to say what you want
yeah absolutely i mean
um i think i am a man in my word we have
communicated with mr child uh an email
so he has that
email which went out yesterday the day
before and there is a condition
on the outline applications submit
requires submission of details
to be agreed by the local authority so
if the council was minded to put an
informative on relaying it back to that
condition
uh to give further consideration i'm
absolutely happy with that
thank you well i think uh uh mr
um bradley heffer uh is
busy uh writing the one sentence for us
to add on
okay is there any other questions to
the ward member no
thank you very much we'll move on we're
open the debate then
um and it's now over to you members have
anyone got any comments dudes or
have you heard at all
right nothing from anybody
okay well the fact that you're all
silent i
intend to propose the officer's
recommendation from the chair
uh plus an added um condition
which uh uh brad the case officer will
read out in a moment
um so would you like to read that out
for me please
thank you chair yeah um in terms of the
framing it within a standard
condition that deals with hard
landscaping um i would suggest the
following sentence
in particular details of the proposed
boundary treatment
to be provided at the boundary of the
site with number eight
pen close are included within the
submission
thank you very much uh i'll add that as
an extra condition do i have a second
for my proposal so that we can proceed
yes so i'll second that mr chairman
uh okay uh councillor osborne
uh thank you
sorry i didn't mean to do that oh right
canceler i was born i say it's come up
yep
okay you're the second dub yeah yeah i
am i
i very much uh uh uh
like uh like the alterations that have
been carried out by
stuart uh mcadam for for on this
application
i think it's uh the revisions have been
very very good
i would just like to make comment that
the
the swift boxes to be agreed with the
final diesel landscape
be included in on on those uh conditions
please
if you could make sure that's there i
think they did say they were there but i
will check that out well
they're not they're not marked down they
they would be included
so we just want to make sure bradley um
officer bradley
can you confirm that
i think to allay the councillors fears
uh chair
what we could do is drag that out of the
um the landscaping condition
and have that as a completely separate
condition so that's completely clear
then
so it isn't lost but i know that the
intention isn't challenged by the
applicant
no okay well i i'll accept that and
you'll cut a second today
so i was born right thank you thank you
i've got
uh two hands up now counselor barrett
followed by councillor busby
are you doing you need to close down um
i don't know what's going on here i
didn't have my hat i must have cancelled
it
right okay i cancelled it and then
inadvertently raised it
um hinton has come up so we'll take him
thank you mr chairman yeah um i wasn't
very happy with this application when it
first
came up partly cameras partly due to the
access through
uh little toughs uh and certainly the
response from highways on that occasion
where they hadn't even been out to look
at the site
was hardly encouraging uh and certainly
looking at the
the the further comments that have been
received from consultees
where you've got the nhs commissioning
group saying uh
they won't even be asking for any money
well if anybody's ever been to the
the branch of the constable country
medical practice which serves
cable they will know that it's a pokey
little place with hardly any space in it
so to have another 300 people probably
potentially descending on it could be
a little bit problematic um the other
thing i don't like
are these um turning circles at the end
of
uh cul-de-sacs particularly where the
impact upon
neighboring properties uh and the
existing development of
cables and mary because you might have
they might have moved the houses away
from the end of
the development coming from
outside of the site
but what makes more noise a house
or traffic turning in a confined space
the fact that there are also private
roads effectively
i find rather worrying because in my own
ward
there have been problems with private
roads where the police of course can
take no
action whatsoever so illegal parking
parking up cars that are not registered
or mot'd or insured or anything else
is completely out of their control and i
would like to see
if this application is going to be
approved that all roads are adopted so
that they're all
all householders are treated in the same
way in terms of their rights
and access and protection under the law
thank you officer bradley
no you've got no comment right no sorry
chair i was just uh
trying to push the right buttons um i've
clearly heard exactly what the the
council's concerns are
i think in relation to the issue of
mitigation section 106 and seal
all i can say is that that issue was
looked at the outline stage we're not
considering
the impact of that and mitigation of
that now
unfortunately um it's it's purely down
to the design and layout they're the
concerns that
we're considering in terms of the way
the the highways work
um clearly the highway authority has an
objection
the functionality issue the cul-de-sac
sorry the movements with regard to
vehicles
we appreciate that that view but again i
think in terms of
the impact in the round the noise that
may be generated by
occasional car movements has to be
quantified as a reason
um against not allowing something and i
think that when you judge
the likely impacts of it the position in
relation to
existing development things like that it
wasn't felt that there was harm being
created
i think allied to that the element of
soft and hard landscaping along the
boundaries
would help to ameliorate the impact of
that somewhat and that's something that
you know would be conditioned we can't
actually
um under planning require all the roads
to be adopted
um that's something for the developer to
take up with um
the highway authority um but as i say
as a planner all i can say is that we're
advised by the highway authority that
the the the road layout that's proposed
does work
thank you councillor hinton you wanted
to come back
uh yes to say that we are looking at
all matters other than the point of
access in this application
so the layout is of concern and if we
turn around and say
no we don't like the layout we're going
to refuse it they will have to go away
and come up with something that's a
little bit more sympathetic to the
existing development of
capable mary and if that includes
adopting all the roads then
why not we can say that
all roads must be constructed to the
same standard
i don't see why we have to have part of
this estate adopted
and part of it not adopted are they just
adopting the piece that is going to take
all the
large agricultural equipment as it
trundles through little tufts and out to
the other end of the fields
because that's basically what it seems
to be then everybody else has to
fend for themselves
um bradley did you want to come back on
that
or have you nothing more to add because
the idea
sorry sorry sorry chair alternative for
councillor hinton will be to
um oppose the um recommendation for
approval
uh but bradley have you got anything to
help councillor hinton
i'm not sure there's anything i can
usually say more in relation to that
chair thank you
thank you councillor buzz uh busby
thank you yeah i tend to share john's
view on this um
it seems to me that when we when we deal
with persimmon
applications we have to fight to get
um a quality end result we looked at the
one and hadley went backwards and
forwards between the planning offices
and the
the applicant a number of times
um we we should only be interested in
quality developments
we're not interested in quantity and it
seems the developers
totally focused on quantity uh
hence we're going to give 100 houses
regardless
i do wish they would consider the the
future impact of what these developments
have on villages
and the costs involved you know
if house of people looking after roads
it's it could look at a tip in about
five to ten years depending on what kind
of surface they use
and getting money out of affordable
housing it's going to be very difficult
when there's something in the report
again
on page 44 13.4 it's considered that the
impacts of the development on the
immunity of existing residents in the
vicinity
would not result in material detriment
so people living in little tufts we've
got to put up with three years
of mud and dust whilst that this is
built out
i think that's quite a considerable
detriment
it really is going to be a pain to live
in though in that close
thank you the only other thing i'd say
our positive point
i hope is that a drying area is only a
drying area providing people who've got
something to dry things on
so i would hope that they're going to
put rotary dryers in
otherwise it's just a walled area
thank you um any
other questions any uh uh counselor
hinton is your hand up again no
no you just haven't put them down that's
all it is right
then if there's no other um comments
it's been proposed and seconded and they
could ask the truth planning officer
uh to read out the proposal on the table
before we go to the vote so i think that
is the um according to the papers
the recommendation by the officers plus
the additional
um condition which i'll just ask quickly
to
re-read to you all thank you
bradley thank you chair
um yes i think that in relation to the
um
the table papers the only the other
thing you should be aware of is right at
the end i think so i've got
i thought i haven't got it up on my
machine but um i think it identifies
that there was double counting in
in relation to a couple of conditions
that were imposed on the outline
um so we correctly value them we
wouldn't need to reimpose them
if planning permission were granted just
to make that clear
but um i think in relation to the the
issue
of uh number eight pen close
um the sentence i was suggesting is in
particular
details of the proposed boundary
treatment to be provided
at the boundary of the site with number
eight
penn close shall be included and that is
within the context of an overall
landscaping condition
thank you thank you very much so members
um who voted on the
um the approval
uh following the submission on page 44
with none of them repeated unnecessarily
plus the additional condition that um
the case offers just
read out right i'm now going to ask the
officer robert carmichael to do a roll
call
thank you chair if you could please
respond with four against or abstain
councillor suez against
councillor melanie barrett four
chance to peter beer four
councillor david busby against
chancellor trevor cresswell
four
mary mclaren paul
councillor adrian osborne
castle lee parker four
and councillor steven plum four
thank you chair i make that carried by
eight votes to three if i could check
with mr depray
yes indeed i agree that was eight votes
to three
uh resolution carried thank you very
much then that is approved by
eight votes to three
uh yep that's right uh thank you very
much members
uh we're now more or less at the end our
next meeting
is due on the
the 29th of july we'll be informed
whether this is still going ahead
in due course uh all that leaves me to
do now is to thank you all for your um
involvement today and i wish you a good
afternoon
thank you very much will you all turn
your cameras off and your mics
thanks bye bye
you